Mein Name ist Lowry. Kein Nachteil, Sir. Nein, es könnte jemand sein. Das ist Information-Retrieval.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 96. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu dieser wiederholten Ausgabe von Chaosradio Express, hier live auf Funkwelle FM. Die vierte und letzte Sendung, denn das Projekt findet auch ab morgen nicht mehr statt. Also der letzte Tag, der hier läuft. Hier wird auch schon so ein bisschen zusammengepackt. Hier ist vier Wochen lang UKW gesendet worden. Im Berliner Raum. Aber wir senden natürlich Chaosradio Express sowieso, wenn es live ist, auch immer live im Internet, wo auch die Funkwelle in der Regel zu erreichen war. Aber auf unseren eigenen Servern unter streamscenem.de kann man auch immer zuhören, wenn es Chaosradio oder Chaosradio Express live gibt. Chaosradio Express ist ein Podcast. Das heißt, uns gibt es auch nach Funkwelle, auch weiterhin, wie es uns schon vorher gegeben hat, im Internet zum Abonnieren und Informationen dazu. Wer Chaosradio Express noch nicht kennt, gibt es auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Und das ccc.de sagt euch auch schon, dass es hierbei um ein Projekt des Chaos Computer Clubs handelt. Mein Name ist wie gesagt Tim Pritlove und ich moderiere hier den Interview-Podcast Chaosradio Express, wo es immer um interessante Themen geht aus Technik und Gesellschaft. Und ich habe gerade jetzt hier bei den vier Ausgaben bei Funkwelle darauf geachtet, Themen zu nehmen, die jetzt noch nicht so einen übermäßigen Nerd-Level haben, sondern die vor allem ein breiteres Interesse erzeugen sollten. Das ist zumindest mein Versuch gewesen. Und so soll es auch diesmal wieder sein. Und heute geht es um die Geschichte der audiovisuellen Kunst bzw. der VJ-Kultur, in die das Ganze heutzutage gemündet hat. Und wir wollen verschiedene Aspekte diskutieren, wie Schlagworte, wie Live-Cinema und vieles andere. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gast bei Chaosradio Express den Falk, Falk Gärtner. Hallo Falk. Na, bist du entspannt?
Ich versuche. Die schockst mich ja immer mit Dingen so live im Radio.
Ich hab dir das vorher gesagt, aber du wusstest es nicht.
Ich dachte, entspannt Podcast, da kann man auch was rausschmeißen.
Nee, sowieso nicht. Ich schmeiß doch nie was weg. Da muss schon was ganz Schlimmes passieren. Heute kannst du dir einfach keinen Lapsus leisten. Ja, Falk, du bist, muss man sich mal ein bisschen vorstellen, du bist ein universeller Spezialexperte. So viel steht auf jeden Fall schon mal fest. Natürlich auch schon seit Jahr und Tag mit Computern unterwegs, aber eben jetzt nicht so der Computer-Nerd, wie man das kennt von der Programmierung her, sondern dein Schwerpunkt ist alles Visuelle. Das heißt, du arbeitest mit mehr Programmen, als ich glaube ich kenne in diesem visuellen Bereich und bist da auch sehr umtriebig. Du bist selber VJ, VJ oder VJ gewesen, das musst du selber beantworten. Vielleicht kannst du ja mal kurz sagen, was so dein Einstieg in die elektronische und vor allem in die visuelle Welt gewesen ist.
Ja, das fing eigentlich ganz früh an. Also ich habe 1989, 86, 87, im Osten auf KC-85 Computern gespielt. Ich hab damals, weil ich gelangen wollte, von Otello nachprogrammieren oder irgendwelchen Datenbanken oder was auch immer, die uns versucht haben, mit uns zu machen. Und hab damals schon eine Animation auf dem KC-85 programmiert. Das war ein ganz schräger Hack, die den Font manipuliert und durchgezeichelt. Das war eigentlich schon eine Animation, mit einer Guillotine und einem Kopfrollte über einer Bildschirme. Ganz minimal. Was ist denn da getragen? Keine Ahnung. Ich hab noch ein bisschen Background in Videoproduktionen, meine Eltern gehabt, die eine Videoproduktionsfirma haben. Ich bin in den 90ern in die Clubszene in Berlin ein bisschen eingestiegen, wie ja so viele. Ich war auch total begeistert darüber. Und so 1996, 1997 fing ich dann an, so eine Verbindung zu sehen, sage ich mal, zwischen Musik und diesem Video und auch diesen Computern, was ich von nebenbei auch immer gemacht habe. Also ich habe dann irgendwie Anfang der 90er auch schon ein bisschen 3D-Animation gemacht und weiterhin natürlich Animationen auf einem Amiga damals. Ja und so Mitte, Ende der 90er habe ich dann das verbunden. Hab dann irgendwie angefangen auf dem Schnittsystem wild rum zu, zur Musik wild rum zu pushen und da schon irgendwelche Rhythmen in normale Videos reinzubringen. Und 1999 bin ich dann das erste Mal darauf gekommen, ja es muss doch auch mit dem Computer gehen. Und dann schräge Videoprogramme damals gefunden. Da war das halt alles so gerade so am Anfang, dass man auch sowas so nicht selber programmieren musste, sondern auch schon so kleine Programme gefunden hat.
Aber nicht mehr mit einem Amiga, oder?
Nee, nee. Also bin dann irgendwann umgestiegen nach dem Tod des Amigas auf dem Megantosh und bin dann da auch bei geblieben. Hab dann 3D auf dem Megantosh gemacht, über Jahre hinweg, wo ich immer noch nach wie vor einen Schmunzeln kriege, auch heutzutage noch, weil ich 3D nach wie vor auf dem Megantosh mache und mittlerweile wesentlich professioneller. Und das war halt Mitte der 90er grausam. Aber ja, da bin dann bei Megantosh geblieben, glücklicherweise, weil auch diese ganze Live-Video-Kunst sich dann schon sehr, sehr Megantosh verlagert hat durch Quicktime und verschiedene Technologien, die es halt wirklich nur auf dem Megantosh damals schon auf den langsamen Computern gab. Und ja, ich bin, sag ich mal so, noch einer der ersten der Laptop-Generationen der VJs. Es gab natürlich vor uns, wenn wir auch gleich noch erfahren, gab natürlich vor den Laptop-VJs noch viele, viele Leute, die sich mit Videokunst und Live-Video-Kunst befasst haben. Aber diese Laptop-VJ-Generationen, wo denn wirklich Laptops stark genug waren, die in den Club zu schleppen und da Live-Video zu machen, da war ich schon mit ganz vor und dabei, würde ich sagen. Und ja, hab dann über die Jahre das weiter verfeinert und bin total draufgegangen auch ein paar Jahre. Hab große Acts, hab bei Van Dyck, Westbam, 20.000 Leute, keine Ahnung, in großen Hallen gespielt, aber halt auch viele kleine Sachen. In jeglichen kleinen Clubs, wo auch immer man mich haben wollte, bin ich hingegangen, weil es mir einfach Spaß gemacht hat, irgendwie Live-Video zu Musik zu machen.
Ja, wir haben uns ja kennengelernt, glaube ich, auf dem Kongress. Wann war das noch mal?
Das muss da als Blinkenlides anfangen, ne?
2001. Genau, da hast du nämlich Blinkenlides-Filme......geremixed....geremixed. So haben wir schon einige Vergangenheit zusammen und ich hab halt immer wieder bewundernd verfolgt und damit eigentlich auch erst erlernt, wie eigenständig eigentlich diese VJ-Kunst auch ist, weil wahrgenommen wird es natürlich in den Clubs dann auch immer so ein bisschen so, ah, das ist der Typ, der neben dem DJ steht und so. Aber ich glaube, das wandelt sich. Aber da wollen wir dann auch später mal hinkommen, wie denn das nun wirklich ist. Zu dir bleibt vielleicht noch hinzuzufügen, machst du jetzt auch Podcasts, oder? Bist du ein bisschen am Quatschen?
Ja, Radio Prototypen, ja, auf den ersten Moment auf unserem Blog. Weil die Webseitenstruktur für alle Webseiten, die so um mich rum ist, die ist noch am Aufbau. Wie immer.
Das sind sie immer.
Aber auf meinem Blog kann man das verfolgen, prototypen.com, slash blog, slash valk, auch in den Links dann wahrscheinlich zu finden.
Aber du bist ja auch ein ganz studierter Mensch und hast dich ja auch ausführlich mit audiovisueller Kunst an sich beschäftigt und wir hatten jetzt hier auch schon so im Vorgespräch hatte ich schon so ein paar Augenöffner. Du verfolgst ja im Prinzip das audiovisuelle, wo ich jetzt mal so vom Gefühl sagen würde, ah ja, so Bild und Musik oder Bild und Ton zusammen, das gibt es auch schon so seit 20 Jahren. Aber du hast den Einstieg etwas früher gesehen, oder?
Ja, also ganz kurz noch mal darauf zu kommen, wie ich überhaupt in dieses Studium reingekommen bin. Also ich habe Kommunikationsdesign studiert, hier in Potsdam und habe mein Diplom über Live-Cinema gemacht, was ich so als Weiterentwicklung vom VJ so sehe und habe daraufhin natürlich geforscht, wo das herkommt. Und habe geforscht und geforscht und so mehr ich geforscht habe, umso tiefer bin ich da reingekommen und umso weiter zurück bin ich in der Geschichte gekommen. Und das ging dann irgendwie, ja war ich da am Anfang des letzten Jahrhunderts, dann war ich irgendwie im Mittelalter, dann war ich irgendwie bei den Griechen und dann war ich irgendwann bei der Höhlenmalerei. Und zwar gab es da irgendwann mal einen Artikel in Nature, also in dem renommierten Fachmagazin, wo alle Wissenschaftler, die irgendwie was auf sich halten, Artikel publizieren und da gab es einen Herrn, der nennt sich Chris Scarra, der hat 1989 dort einen Artikel publiziert, wo er zwei Palantäologen zitiert, die herausgefunden haben, dass alle Höhlenmalereien in den französischen Pyrenäen, in den Höhlen der französischen Pyrenäen, also die ältesten Höhlenmalereien, die man gefunden hat, immer an den Stellen zu finden sind, wo die Resonanz der Musik am stärksten ist. Sprich, er geht davon aus, dass diese Bilder gemalt wurden, während Musik getrommelt war. Damals gab es Trommeln und auch primitive Flöten. Ich hab mich daraufhin, da haben wir das gewechselt, waren gleich daraufhin damit auch ein bisschen auseinander gefasst, es gab primitive Flöten wohl damals und Trommeln und sie gehen davon aus, dass diese Höhlenmalereien gemalt wurden, während Musik gespielt wurde. Sprich eigentlich schon so ein bisschen ein Vorausblick auf VJs.
Irgendwie fester Beat, irgendwie enger, stickige Räume und alle drehen total durch.
Flackernde Lampen, die ja auch so... Genau.
Geschichte wiederholt sich.
Ja, spannende Sache. Und natürlich gibt es dann Löcher im Research. Weiter ging es dann eigentlich schon mit den Griechen. Das war dann schon der nächste Schritt.
Um das gleich noch mal eins zu machen. Audiovisuell siehst du sozusagen, das ist so mit der Betonung auf das Visuelle, also das ist ja das, was wir jetzt erforschen wollen. Aber es geht jetzt sozusagen wirklich um das Bild im Kontext mit dem Ton.
Genau, und eigentlich sogar noch live. Da werden wir jetzt natürlich ein bisschen abweichen von, weil bestimmte Sachen einfach so dermaßen beeinflusst haben, die nicht unbedingt live waren und auch technisch halt nicht möglich waren live. Aber eigentlich geht es darum, auch das live zu erzeugen, wie auch Musik live eigentlich am besten erzeugt wird. Da auch am meisten Feedback stattfindet. Also live, audio und visuell, das sind so die drei Schlagworte, die wir uns hier eigentlich unterhalten.
Und nach den Höhlen, Merlern?
Da kamen dann so die Griechen mit ihren Delphi, den Orakelen, auch wieder Drogen stark im Spiel, nehmen wir an.
Ja, da liegt.
Vor allen Dingen Herr Pythagoras, den ja jeder kennt. Der mit dem Dreieck. Genau, der hat die Theorie der Musik der Kugeln erfunden. Da setzt er die Tonation von Musik mit Kugelgrößen gleich. Genau hintergestiegen bin ich da auch nicht, ich bin ein bisschen rübergeflogen. Aber viel interessanter ist Herr Plato, den auch wieder alle kennen, der diese Musik der Kugeln als Grundlage genommen hat, um Farben zu tönen, zu verbinden. Also bestimmte Tonlagen, bestimmte Tonnoten zu bestimmten Farben zu matchen. Also zu sagen, C ist rot oder...
Warum? Also so als Erkenntnis oder so?
Weil das ja, das eine ist so, wir bewegen uns da in der gesamten Geschichte immer zwischen Physik und Metaphysik, sag ich jetzt mal dazu. Also alles, was so gefühlt ist und eigentlich was mathematisch beschrieben werden kann. Das ist immer so ein Battle zwischen den beiden. Eigentlich bis heutzutage. Heutzutage ist es mehr Technik und mehr Philosophie dahinter. Damals aber auch schon diese zwei Pole. Also man hatte gefühlt, irgendwie gibt es eine Verbindung zwischen Bildern und Tönen. Aber man konnte sie nicht, man wollte sie beschreiben, irgendwie über Formeln. Peter Grass hat ja damals auch schon drei, kann man ja gerade sagen. Aber Plato ist ja noch ein bisschen mehr philosophisch unterwegs und wollte...
Das waren ja alles universale Spezialexperten damals. Ich glaube ja fast nichts, was sie gemacht haben, lange Zeit. Das hat sie auch eine Weile gehalten. Und was ist da jetzt bei rausgekommen, bei Plato mit den Farben und den Kugeln? Der hat da so eine Farbtabelle aufgestellt.
Er hat noch keine Farbtabelle aufgestellt, er hat erst mal so die Theorie aufgestellt, dass es eine Verbindung geben könnte. Er hat versucht, da eine Farbtabelle aufzustellen, aber da gibt es keine Überlieferung, was hat er da jetzt genau?
Könnte man ja mit der heutigen Sichtweise auf die Welt sagen, Farben sind auch nur Frequenzen?
Richtig, Wellen. Da kommen wir nämlich, ich bringe mich jetzt auch gleich weiter zu Herrn Newton, da sind wir richtig in der Physik. Der, der das hat, wo man runterfällt.
Also, Plato hat nur gesagt, dass mir die Kugeln gefällt mir irgendwie, wo wir eh schon so metaphysisch unterwegs sind, dann pack ich doch da noch mal mit Farben.
Wie gesagt, es ist davon auszugehen, dass er das spezifiziert hat, es gibt aber keine Dokumente da drüber. Ja, und dann springen wir ja im Mittelalter, keine Ahnung, weil dann gab es dann nicht so richtig viel Überlieferungen in der Zwischenzeit. Also es ist definitiv klar, dass da weiter geforscht wurde, auch mit vielen berauschenden Mitteln.
Würdest du mir jetzt sagen, dass die Römer nicht so prinzipiell was beigetragen haben zu dem Thema?
Ich hab nicht gefunden. Ich bin ja auch immer offen. Also es ist ein Research in Progress für immer. Also ich denke, dass ich da auch noch weiter was finde. Ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen, dass es jetzt alles, was zu fissen gibt.
Klar, in der Partykultur waren die ja auf jeden Fall ganz gut vertreten.
Die Römer?
Ja, also von dem, was man so hört. Wussten sie zumindest zu feiern.
Aber wahrscheinlich die falschen Drohungen. Die haben ja eher Alkohol so, dem Alkohol gefröhnt.
Manche haben keine Bilder gesehen, geschweige denn gemalt. Wer weiß. Wir lassen das offen. Aber wo ist die nächste Erkenntnis? Also wir überspringen sozusagen.
Wir überspringen jetzt mal so ein paar Jahrhunderte.
Wie man das so macht in der professionellen Geschichtsforschung.
Nichts gefunden. Also ich habe wirklich gesucht und gesucht. Da fehlen mir wirklich auch Lücken. Ich würde die Lücken super gerne füllen.
Wir sind ja auch schon so weit hinten. Also wenn ich mal jetzt von 20, 30 Jahren, die ich erwartet hatte, ausgehe und wir fangen mal in den Höhlen an, müssen wir jetzt auch mal was überspringen, sonst kriegen wir das ja nicht in zwei Stunden unter.
Wir kommen nämlich zu Herrn Newton, das ist der, der das mit der Gravitation gefunden hat, dem der Apfel auf den Kopf fallen ist. Und der ist der erste, der dann auch wirklich mal eine Farbmusiktabelle aufgemacht hat. Wir sind jetzt wirklich noch in den rudimentären, wir versuchen, Töne mit Farben zu matchen und viel mehr gibt es dann auch erstmal.
Was Plato sozusagen nagelegt hat, dass man da mal drüber nachdenken könnte, wurde dann von Newton spätestens...
Ist auch wieder auf Pythagoras. Die Kugeln hat dann das irgendwie mit Wellen zusammen, Wellen hat der glaube ich noch nicht, aber hat auf jeden Fall...
Wir rätseln.
Wir rätseln, auf jeden Fall hat er eine klassische Farbmusiktabelle. Also C ist rot und D ist grün, müsst ihr jetzt gucken.
Wir sind ja im Podcast, musst du das jetzt so plastisch beschreiben? Das ist jedem klar, aber ich glaube, die Farben können wir schon übermitteln.
Genau und diese Farbmusiktabelle war eigentlich schwierig. Also er selber hat noch gesagt, habe ich das hier stehen eigentlich, ein Verständnis über die Verbindung von Farbe und Ton kann nicht ausreichend bewiesen werden, das gibt keinen objektiven Beweis. Das hat Newton selber zu dem Zeitpunkt gesagt, wo er diese Tabelle hergestellt hat. Weil nämlich, es haben danach auf dieser Grundlage von Newton eine ganze Menge andere, sehr bekannte Persönlichkeiten, das versucht weiter zu erfolgen. So Goethe, Rousseau, Castel, das ist der mit den Bleistiften. Ski Rabin ist ein bekannter Komponist, Rimmington. Ski Rabin ist ein russischer Komponist. Das war auch der erste Komponist, der aus der Audiokette kam, der auch so versucht hat, Farben da auch mit in seine Kunstwerke, er wollte eigentlich eine Notation schaffen, wo man Farben und Ton gleichzeitig spielen kann.
Wo man Farben spielen kann?
Genau, da gabs nämlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wir sind jetzt hier so um 1800 rum, sowohl vom Castell als auch vom Remington, die haben dann angefangen Farborgeln herzustellen. Man muss sich vorstellen, kein elektrisches Licht, keine Motoren, kein irgendwas, also alles, was man heutzutage an Farbpflichtspielen kennt, mal aus dem Kopf rausschmeißen, sondern die haben Klaviere umgebaut mit kleinen Fähnchen, die so Farbvorhänge vor Öllampen geschoben haben.
Nein.
So, ganze Palette, also zum Anfang wirklich nur...
Lass dich nicht verwirren, das ist hier das Studio-Telefon, das ist nicht für uns.
Zum Anfang wirklich nur kleine Fensterchen beleuchtet von hinten, aber die haben dann schon versucht auch Räume farblich zu gestalten. Und jetzt Gera Bean hat diese Farbmusik-Orgeln von Remington und Castell als Anlass genommen auch eine Notation dafür zu finden. Aber eigentlich sind wir noch bei dieser Farbmusiktabelle, die nämlich gar nicht funktioniert hat.
Diese Farborgeln faszinieren mich gerade total, also der Gedanke, dass man da auf so einer Klaviatur rumspielt und dann wird da so eine Farbe vor Öl am Zerflach.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da noch eine Bildergalerie danach hinstellen. Es gibt da schon geile Bilder dazu. Es gibt ja die tollen Links bei Chaosradio Express.
Musstest du es aber auch erwähnen? Also wo du hinlinken willst. Ja, wir bauen ein paar Links ein mit bunten Bildern. Vielleicht nehmen wir sogar eine Farborgel.
Ja, ich habe eine Farborgel. Ich habe auch glaube ich einen linksen Farborgel. Also wirklich, muss man sich das vorstellen, wie die damals so mit Schnüren und so kleine Vorhänge bewegt haben. Und die funktionierten auch alle nur einmal einmal oder zweimal maximal und dann brannten sie ab, weil mit den Öllampen dahinter und alles heiß wurde natürlich, wenn du kleine Kämmerchen hast, wo die Öllampen drin sind.
Interessant, was da so für ein psychedelischer Drang offensichtlich vorliegt, so eine Kombination überhaupt zu erstellen, ne?
Seit den Griechener halt im Prinzip, wo man das erstmal durch niedergeschrieben hat, wahrscheinlich schon vorher. Ja, man sieht halt Musik, also das ist halt Musik und da ist noch Bild und irgendwie, also für mich jetzt als VJ, da ist ein Bauchgefühl da, wie es sich verbindet. Also ich höre Musik, ich sehe da Bilder zu oder ich fühle die Musik und dann kann ich weiß ich, was für Bilder zu diesem Gefühl passen, automatisch irgendwie.
Es gibt auch Leute, die das besonders ausgeprägt haben.
Genau, die diese Musik halt sehen, sind es Thesis-Ten, da kommen wir gleich zu, in drei Stichpunkten. Weil erstmal möchte ich diesen Farbmusik-Dings, den Durchstoß durchs Herz versetzen, weil nämlich diese ganzen Leute, die dafür geforscht haben, die eigentlich die gleiche Grundlage hatten, nämlich diese Newton-Farbmusiktabelle, haben alle ihre eigenen Farbmusiktabellen gemacht und am Ende kam halt raus, dass diese ganzen Farbmusiktabellen, die diese ganzen Leute aufgestellt haben, nebeneinander liegt. Es gibt keinerlei Übereinstimmung, es ist wirklich von blau bis grün zu einer Note alles dabei, also es gibt keine Übereinstimmung. Wenn man die Farb, da gibt es diese Gegenübererstellung, wenn man die sieht, ist es klar, über die Jahrhunderte hinweg, über verschiedene Menschen hinweg, es ist nicht im Kopf irgendwo klar festgelegt, rot ist C, beziehungsweise es ist nur im Kopf festgelegt und so in den jeweiligen einzelnen Köpfen, aber es gibt einfach keinerlei Code, keinerlei Genetik oder sonst irgendwie physikalische Entsprechung, trotz der... Von Goethe-Zitat vielleicht so, um den Podcast aufzuwerten. Gibt es noch ein super schönes Dirk.
Ja, was hat er gesagt?
Also er spricht halt über Formen, also über Farben und Musik.
Ja, jetzt sind wir wirklich bei der Wallachschule, ist ja klar, ne?
Sie sind wie zwei Flüsse, die ihren Ursprung in ein und demselben Berg haben, aber nach und nach verfolgen sie ihren Weg unter vollkommenen verschiedenen Bedingungen in zwei vollständigen verschiedenen Regionen, sodass während des gesamten Verlaufs die beiden keine zwei Punkte verglichen werden können. Also zwei Flüsse, die zwar nebeneinander irgendwie fließen, aber sie treffen sich nie und verbinden sich nie zu irgendwas.
Also mit anderen Worten der Abgesang an die Verbindung, also an die direkte Entsprechung zwischen Musik und Bild. Aber trotzdem gab es halt immer wieder den Drang, doch das eine zu dem anderen zu komponieren und niemand wird in Abrede stellen, dass es natürlich möglich ist, das passende Bild zu finden.
Für eine persönliche Einschätzung natürlich. Bild sind wir ja aber auch, und ich bin erst mal nur bei Farben. Das geht mich jetzt erstmal weiter. Die Farbtheorie wurde jetzt dann erweitert. Man hat festgestellt, okay Farben, das ist jetzt nicht so die Erfüllung. Vielleicht, wenn man dann Formen dazu nimmt, wird es dann vielleicht besser. Und wurde dann auch besser, wie du ja auch vorhin feststellen konntest. Das hat schon auch eine Form, haben auch schon eine gewisse, ja, gewisse Gefühl mehr als nur eine Farbe. Herr Kestner hat dann versucht, Tonhöhen und Helligkeiten in Verbindung zu setzen.
Wer war das? Erich Kestner. Ja, aber der, der auch die Bücher geschrieben hat oder ganz jemand anderes?
Hat er Bücher geschrieben?
Das schneide ich jetzt raus.
Ich weiß ja nicht, nee, nicht Kestner, nicht K-K-E-S-T-N, Kerstner. Ach so, Kerstner. Auf jeden Fall hat der Tonhöhen mit Helligkeit versucht. Also hoher Ton mit einer hellen Farbe und zusätzlich noch Sättigung mit Lautstärke. Also lauter Ton ist halt mehr saturiert als ein leiser Ton, der dann eher pastel ist. Da war für mich schon die Frage so, warum ist nicht ein hoher Ton eine Pastellfarbe? Also ein hoher Ton auch ein ungesättigter Ton. Also das kann man auch umdrehen. Also da gibt es schon, das widerspricht sich schon, da gab es auch diesen Farbmusik-Kongress 1938, glaube ich, wo dieses auch dem Deutschdurchs zum Opfer gefallen ist.
Farbmusik-Kongress.
Den gab es fünfmal.
Wie hat sich da getroffen?
Komponisten, solche Leute hier.
Steinzeit-VJs.
Hier in Deutschland.
In Berlin oder was?
Ja, genau. Und in Holland auch einmal. Letzte war in Holland. Aber schon in Europa. Hier ist ein deutschsprachiger Raum. Ganz stark vertreten.
Farbmusik-Kongress. Was wollen die? Sind das jetzt Forscher oder sind das Künstler oder kann man das gar nicht so richtig trennen?
Das sind so, na ja, wie auf Plateau alles.
Alles noch die universellen Spezialexperten. Na gut, so in den 30er Jahren gab es da auch noch so einige von.
Das ist glaube ich auch erst danach. Viele Musiker natürlich auch, also Komponisten, die versucht haben, ihre Musik noch in ein anderes Element zu geben. Das ist immer wieder, da kommt man auch, da bin ich nicht ganz so fit, was die klassische Musik betrifft, aber da kommen halt immer auch wieder so ein paar Namen, die man wohl kennen muss. Denen nicht dienen kannst.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt sozusagen im 20. Jahrhundert angekommen? Also zusammengefasst, schon irgendwie den Höhlenmalereien wird ihnen zumindest jetzt unterstellt. Ich meine, ob die nun recht gehabt haben, diese Aussage mit hier klingt jetzt besonders gut, ich weiß nicht, was die gemacht haben.
Die haben ja gemessen. Also richtig so.
Die haben sich da tagelang in die Höhle gestellt und über lang getrommelt oder haben die das einfach so?
Nee, die haben richtig gemessen, also da ist die Resonanz. Ich bin kein Tontechniker, aber man weiß ja, dass in einem Raum, bestimmter Ort immer die beste Resonanz hat. Also da haben wir nicht so eine Echo oder was. Ja genau, und das klingt da am besten. Und immer genau an dem Punkt war eine Höhlenmalerei und nirgends war das. Also es war halt nicht, die haben es halt nicht gesagt, ja das sind überall Höhlenmalereien und das könnte so sein, dass da so besonders große und schicke Sondern, es waren immer nur an diesen Punkten Höhlenmalereien. Also das ist schon ein deutlicher Hinweis.
Könnte also tatsächlich so sein, dass sie sich das wirklich danach ausgesucht haben. Wo machen wir denn mal ein Bild? Mal ertrommeln.
Krass. Und dann von da an halt ja so Farbmusik, also dass man erst mal nur versucht hat, Farben bis zum späten 19. Jahrhundert, also so bis 1860, 70, also nur versucht hat, Farben zu matchen mit irgendwie Tönen. Und dann kommen dann halt Formen dazu, das ist dann die sogenannte Formmusik. Also da hab ich das jetzt mal getauft, du hörst gar nicht auf Formmusik, so als Begriff, wo man halt versucht hat, diese Farben schon dann zu erweitern mit irgendwelchen Formen. Und da haben wir eben gerade gesagt, Tonhöhen mit Helligkeit, das ist eigentlich nur Farbe, aber da gibt es nämlich dann den ersten Beweis, da sind wir halt mit diesen Synesthesiasten und die wir eben schon besprochen haben, das sind halt ganz interessante Leute, da gibt es halt...
Heißen die so? Synesthesiasten?
Ich denke, dass die so heißen.
Okay, Synesthesie.
Das ist, wenn man einen Ton hört und ein Bild sieht, da gibt es eine ganze Menge Studien drüber, weil das total interessant ist, dass es halt irgendwie so einen Kopf falsch verknotet, sozusagen. Die Leute empfinden es selber auf der einen Seite als sehr spannend, also die haben auch Spaß dran, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es auch sehr stressig, weil wenn du in die Stadt gehst und es ist laut, sehen die halt permanent irgendwelche Sachen. Also die brauchen halt auch viel Ruhe, diese Leute, überhaupt klar zu kommen, weil sonst hast du permanent Bilder.
Also da gibt es ja verschiedene Ausprägungsformen von dieser Synesthesie-Geschichte.
Genau, gibt es auch andere Formen.
Es gibt Leute, die haben Geschmäcker bei Tönen, und das bezieht sich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer nur auf Musik, oder? Oder ist das im Wesentlichen eine Interpretation?
Nein, nein, es sind Töne generell.
Töne, Tonhöhe, was auch immer. Und das eine wird von dem einen irgendwie über den Geschmack entfunden. Also löst halt im Körper was aus, was auch durch Geschmack ausgelöst wird. Ich sag's mal so rum. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man auf einmal so ein salziges Gefühl im Maul hat, aber man spürt vielleicht irgendwie dasselbe, was man eben hat. Keine Ahnung, da steckt man ja nie drin. Aber davon habe ich auch gehört, dass die dann eben auch so Sachen haben wie Farben-Assoziation.
Und Formen auch.
Und Formen auch sagst du. Und was heißt das Formen? Das heißt irgendwie du bläst Tuba und dann sehe ich Kreise.
Oder gehen auf der örte Straße und die sehen eckige, spitze Formen. Ich bin selber nicht. Ich kann die sagen, was die genau sind.
Was siehst du denn?
Es gab auch eine schöne, schicke Diplom-Arbeit vor mir bei uns an der Uni. Die hat nur über Sinistätisten...
Welche Uni ist das, haben wir da schon gesagt?
Da müssen wir mal googeln. Da haben wir jetzt den Link nicht parat. Aber das ist auch eine schicke Diplom-Arbeit. Die hat auch mehrere solcher Leute getroffen mit denen Interviews geführt. Und da gibt es auch nach wie vor solche. Ja, und da die ersten, die das so herausgefunden haben, dass es solche Leute gibt, Namen habe ich jetzt nicht schon.
Ist das eine Entdeckung der Neuzeit?
Die gibt es schon immer. Die ersten gibt es garantiert schon immer. Genau wie es Krebs schon immer gibt.
Ja klar, aber dass man auch wirklich jetzt hingegangen ist und das als Phänomen beschreibt, weil normalerweise werden die Leute ja wahrscheinlich eher in der Kategorie Spinner abgeschoben.
Ja, 1938 gab es so die erste Forschung dazu. Also die erste großflächig angelegte, wo man mehrere Leute mal so richtig untersucht hat, über einen längeren Zeitraum befragt hat und wer die Töne vorher gespielt hat und so weiter. Und festgestellt hat, dass die nicht crazy sind oder so, sondern das ist wirklich... und daraus gab es dann auch gleich den allerersten, also den allerersten und eigentlich auch den einzigen Beweis zu einer wirklich richtigen Verbindung, weil alle dieser Sinisterier da sind. Die haben alle andere Farben gesehen, die haben alle andere Formen gesehen, zu gleichen Musik oder zu gleichen Tönen oder zu gleichen Umständen. Das Eins, was alle gleich gesehen haben, ist, dass es schnelle Musik oder schnelle Töne, schnelle Tonabfolgen, eckig und spitz waren.
Schnelle Töne waren eckig und oder spitz?
Schnelle Töne gibt es ja nicht, aber schnelle Tonabfolgen haben eckige und spitze Formen generiert.
Bei allen?
Bei allen.
Oder alle, die sich zu Formen geäußert haben, überhaupt?
Ja genau, also alle, die überhaupt Formen sehen bei Musik.
Aber die Farbenfreaks waren nicht eckig und spitz?
Na ja, wenn du irgendwie Musik siehst, siehst du nicht nur Farben, siehst immer gleich Formen mit. Ah, okay, interessant.
Eckig und spitz.
Eckig und spitz. Also Spikes, keine Ahnung. Das ist auch...
Und das gilt als Beweis? Das gilt als Beweis, dass man sagen kann, dass es hier keine...
Genau, also dass es da im Kopf wahrscheinlich irgendwas ist, was wirklich schnell irgendwie du eckig und spitz Kohle ist, also zusammen baust.
Das heißt, dann setzt du auch das erste Mal richtig dann auch eine Forschung ein, damit sozusagen?
Ja, damit war eigentlich erstmal die andere alte Forschung, Farbmusik, erstmal gegessen. Ja, also auch komplett gegessen erstmal. Also da war das Abgehakt für alle.
Also jetzt irgendwie geil, wir sind jetzt auf Form. Wir haben jetzt so den Trend gefunden, wie Goethe und Plato wurden abgewählt.
Genau. Und auf Form ist man dann auch die nächsten Jahre halt promiriert, stark. Da gab es dann auch die ersten Geräte von Herrn Thomas Wilfried zum Beispiel, den Klavi-Lux aus dem kleinen Fernseher. Der hat Formplatten, wilde... Also es sah halt aus wie eine Schallplatte, die du da eingelegt hast und hast da reingeguckt und hast gedreht und dann hast du Formen gesehen, die sich immer wieder verändert haben, wenn du angeguckt hast. Und dann konntest du auch so Musik dazu einlegen und das hat dann so gematcht eigentlich immer.
Klavi-Lux. Wie muss man sich das so vorstellen, dieses Gerät?
Ja, wie gesagt, so wie so ein Fernseher zum reingucken. So eine Jukebox, so ein bisschen so. Dann hast du eine Platte eingelegt und hast halt wilde Formen gesehen. Diese Formmusik, wie gesagt, das ist schon so der Grundporstein für alt, was dann jetzt gleich kommt. Ich weiß nicht, wie wir da jetzt so den Bogen so smooth hinkriegen.
Ich guck hier gerade nach dem Klavi-Lux. Also der schreibt sich mit C.
Das sieht so ein bisschen aus.
Hier ist ein Fernseher erst mal. Und der hat diese Bilder hier gemacht? Nein. Unglaublich. Ich brauch einen Videopodcast. Wie hat das funktioniert?
Wie gesagt, das ist so eine Platte. Da sind so Formen drauf. Da sind aber doch die Platte eben zu sehen, oder?
Ja, ich bin hier gerade mal so ein bisschen am Gucken.
Da links oben sind diese Platten, siehst du die?
Ja, okay, richtige Scheiben.
Richtig, richtige Scheiben. Und da sind so eine Formen drauf irgendwie, die er darauf gemalt hat, und die kannst du so einlegen, und dann kannst du dir das anschauen. Anschauen zu Musik. Also er hat dann wohl auch diese Formen.
Im Prinzip einfach eine bemalte Schallplatte. Schallplatte ohne Schall. Einfach nur so eine Bildplatte. Und dann wurde das irgendwie zum Angucken und so. Aha, ist ja krass. So eine Art VJ-Heimkino, so eine Art artificiertes Kaminfeuer.
Er hat auch gesagt, ein Klavi-Lux würde in jedem Wohnzimmer stehen. Im Fernseher, das auch voraus ist, ist ja noch weit vorm Fernseher. Auch im Fernseher, das voraus gesagt. Dass halt jeder sich zu Hause so ein Klavi-Lux hinstellt und dann darauf fest trippt zu verschiedenen Musikern. Also er wollte dann halt auch noch Musik dazu. Also dass dann auf der Schallplatte wahrscheinlich dann die Musik gleich mit abspielt, nehme ich an. Und das ist so die Formmusik. Und die Formmusik geht eigentlich, also dieser Klavi-Lux ist ja noch filmlos, aber wir kommen jetzt auch schon so, das ist schon die Zeit, wo die Anfänge des Films sind.
Genau, aber noch ohne Audio.
Noch ohne Audio, ja, mit Orchester.
Ja, mit Musikbegleitung, aber der Tonfilm, ich weiß gar nicht, seit wann gibt es den Tonfilm? Tonfilm musste auch so in den 30er-Jahren aufgekommen sein.
Ja, 1998, ich möchte nicht weiter sagen, also dieses gefährliche Halbwissen immer.
Also da gab es so frühe Sachen hier, also 36, ja, das ist so diese Gegend, 36 war der Stumpf-Film sozusagen abgelöst und behauptet die allwissende Müllhalle zumindest, weiß gar nicht, ob das stimmt. Das heißt, da, das ist ja eigentlich sozusagen das audiovisuelle in Reinkultur. Also das ist ja jetzt so, heute sind wir es gewohnt. Audiovisuell ist halt natürlich ein Tonfilm, irgendwas läuft als Video ab und dazu gibt es irgendwie Musik oder umgekehrt, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war das dann halt was vollkommen Neues. Das hast du aber jetzt sozusagen in deiner geschichtlichen Herleitung, dürfte das ja auch ein relativ wichtiger Baustein sein.
Na klar, also schon von ganz ganz früh in den Anfangen des Films hat man versucht, abstrakt irgendwie mit dem Medium umzugehen, also mit reinritzen und raufmalen und sonst irgendwas und auch immer in Verbindung zu bringen mit Musik. Total interessant, das fing ganz am Anfang schon an. Da gibt es Fetzen von unbekannten Leuten, wo man nicht weiß, wo das herkommt, wo man halt denkt, es ist garantiert irgendwie zu Musik gestaltet worden. Das ist noch weit vor dem, was ich jetzt nämlich sage, das sind nämlich die ersten Namen, die das dazu gibt, ist dann Walter Ruttmann. Und Walter Ruttmann, vor allem für sein Epos Sinfonie einer Großstadt bekannt, auch wieder sehr Berlin bezogen, hat aber vorher vor diesem Sinfonie einer Großstadt wesentlich abstrakte Filme gemacht. Mit dem Opus 1 angefangen 1921. Da hat er sich damals schon gestritten mit dem Hans Richter, der 1921 mit dem Rhythmus 21 auch so einen abstrakten Musikfilm gemacht hat. Also da geht's halt vorm. Wir sind nahe vor bei der Formmusik. Ja, da warst du vorhin so baff. Die haben halt wirklich...
Das Ding ist auf YouTube. Und ich bin komplett nach hinten umgefallen, weil erst mal das von seiner Bildsprache her so modern wirkte irgendwie. Das war natürlich simpel, ja, aber ganz klar nichts, was man jetzt in dieser Zeit so aus dem Gefühl heraus verorten wurde und vor allem Farbe. Also es handelt sich um Farbfilme.
Weil sie auch gemalt haben. Also das war jetzt keine Museum, die Farbe hergestellt hat, sondern die haben wirklich mit Farbstiften auf den 35 Millimeter kleinen...
Das ist aber auch schon die passende Farbe dafür gehabt, die irgendwie diese Licht-Dingsung da ausgehalten hat. Die haben da auf jeden Fall einen Weg gefahren. Und die haben da wirklich Bild für Bild bemalt, sozusagen. Um dann also im Prinzip so Stop-Motion...
Stop-Motion ist krass.
Aber Animation, Bild für Bild, irgendwie zusammensetzen, so wie man später auch Trickfilme gemacht hat.
Genau, bemalt, gekratzt, aufhinein irgendwelche krassen Objekte gefilmt, die dann irgendwelche Rhythmen gebegeben haben. Also waren auch sehr kreativ.
Das waren dann aber einfache Tonfolgen, die dann...
Der schönste, großen Chor...
.kleine Kompositionen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt gerade nicht mehr so eine Erinnerung war.
Nein, das ist ein Orchester, also mit Orchesterbegleitung dann schon gewesen. Also bevor es Tonfilme gab, mit Orchesterbegleitung.
Das heißt, er hat sozusagen das Bild geliefert zur Orchestermusik? Während sonst eigentlich in der Zeit das Orchester dann immer die Musik zum Bild geliefert hat. Das heißt, die haben dann eigentlich das erste Mal den Spieß umgedreht und gesagt, wir interpretieren jetzt die Musik, während sonst eigentlich die Musik immer das Geschehen interpretiert hat.
Ja, genau, kann man schon so sagen. Ja, wusste genau, wenn man sich das so anguckt, das ist synchron. Also da passiert wirklich, Orchester switcht und auf einmal switchen auch die Grafiken auf den Links. Die Synchronisität zwischen beiden ist da phänomenal. Also das wurde bis vor drei Jahren. Kann man das mit dem Rechner nicht nachlesen.
Und steht der Film die Symphonie einer Großstadt? Also es ist ja dieser Film über Berlin, wo Berlin über 24 Stunden gezeigt wird und unglaublich viele Sequenzen aus dem täglichen Berliner Leben. Ich weiß nicht, in welchem Jahr hat er das gemacht?
27.
27, also das Berlin der späten 20er Jahre wird dort porträtiert. Erstaunlich, habe mir den neulich mal angeguckt. Da gibt es ja auch noch so ein Remake, der 2002 gemacht wurde. Aber wirklich beeindruckende Informationsdichte. Und dazu halt eben symphonischer Sound.
Genau, es ist sehr interessant, weil alle, die mit dem Medienfilm sowas gemacht haben, sind früher oder später da hingekommen. Ja, dass diese abstrakten Sachen ja ganz schön sind, aber eigentlich noch viel cooler eine Geschichte zu erzählen, auch wenn sie abstrakt ist, aber eine Geschichte wirklich mit realen Bildern zu erzählen. Also es ist jetzt nicht nur Herr Ruttmann, dem das so gegangen ist, sondern auch Herr Fischinger, zu dem ich gleich noch kommen würde, der das dann auch eher natürlich im späten Leben dann auch wieder abstrakter geworden ist, aber so zwischendurch eher versucht hat, visuelle Storys zu erzählen in Verbindung zu Musik, was mein Ansatz im Moment so ein bisschen ist, aber da kommen wir jetzt zum Schluss noch zu, war schon mal so als im Hinterkopf behalten. Weil der Herr Ruttmann hat ja diese Opus 1 bis 8 gemacht, zwischen 21 und 26, und dann hat er die Sinfonie einer Großstadt gefilmt und die Opus 1 bis 18 komplett abstrakt. Das ist das, wenn man heute so als VJ, abstrakte VJs in Clubs, ich darf ja immer das nicht sagen, aber Bewegtbild-Tapete, sag ich jetzt mal dazu. Werd ich ja immer böse angeguckt. Aber du bist irgendwo im Club und guckst an die Wand, und das sind halt abstrakte Formen, die sich irgendwie zur Musik so mit bewegen. Und hat dann aber irgendwie die Lust dran verloren. Also wir verlieren alle irgendwie so die Lust dran nach, in diesen rein abstrakten Formen. Wir wollen dann auf einmal alle irgendwie doch eine Handlung reinbringen und doch irgendwie auch richtige Bilder zeigen, die irgendwie in sich selber eine Geschichte erzählen, aber auch als großes Gesamtding eine Geschichte erzählen. Und das ist mein Ansatz. Da hake ich so einen mit dem, wo ich dann halt hin will. Das ist immer im Hintergrund wie eine Halbhälfte. Aber die Sinfonie an der Großstadt ist schon auch visuell, also auch das allererste, definitiv der allererste, der Realbilder zur Musik gematcht hat.
Hat er denn die Bilder zur Musik arrangiert oder hat er nicht die Sinfonie für die Bilder gemacht?
Ich würde sagen, er hat die Musik zuerst gehabt. Aber ich weiß es nicht genau, ich hab da nichts gefunden. Das ist so wie mit seinem Opus 1 bis 8, wo er auch die Musik definitiv vorher gehabt haben muss. Also das geht nicht andersrum. Hat er da auch, glaube ich, ist er nicht anders, hat er das nicht wieder zurückgehend gemacht. Er hatte erst diese Sinfonie.
Ich glaube, das war auch bei dem Remake so. Also das war da sicherlich auch ein bisschen parallel. Aber es ist nicht so, dass dann die Sinfonie erst nach einer Zusammenstellung der Bilder, das kann man sich auch irgendwie gar nicht vorstellen. Aber klar, es gab dann natürlich den groben Plan, was man zeigen will, was man filmen will. Dann hat man die Bilder, hat irgendwas ausgewählt. Das wäre noch mal interessant. Wir können eigentlich nur Mutmaßen. Da müsste man mal hinterfragen, wie der Prozess da jetzt tatsächlich gelaufen ist. Ich glaube, ich habe irgendwann mal eine Dokumentation gesehen über dieses Remake, aber ich kann mich partout nicht daran erinnern, ob das nun erwähnt wurde. Nur halt, dass diese Sinfonie für diesen Film explizit komponiert wurde. Aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das ja ein relativ zeitaufwändiger Prozess ist, dass die Musik halt dann da war. Insofern wäre auch das quasi wieder VJ-Kultur. Also man nimmt einfach Realbilder, um Musik zu interpretieren, um letzten Endes wiederum eine Geschichte zu erzählen. Das heißt, diese Sinfonie, der gilt ja heute als totaler Klassiker, aber ist halt mehr als nur so ein Doku-Klassiker, sondern es ist auch jetzt rein vom konzeptionellen her schon auch ein besonderer Film. Also es ist nicht nur besonders, weil er Berlin gezeigt hat, sondern er ist besonders, wie er überhaupt irgendetwas...
Weit draußen, also zu der Zeit irgendwie so abstrakt. Es gab ja dann noch den Man with a Moving Camera, der aus Russland kam, der auch so ein bisschen in die Richtung ging. Das ist auch so ein bisschen wie in so einer Großstadt nur russisch. Da hab ich jetzt mal sehr patriotisch und Arbeiterklasse gezeigt und auch ähnlich so Tagesablauf in einem Sozialismus gezeigt. Auch so um die Zeit glaube ich. Das war sogar noch drei Jahre früher oder so. Nicht so richtig zur Wirtunion, so zu sagen. Technologisch alles benutzt, sowohl er als auch man with a Moving Camera, der auch schon erst mal so eine Kamera, die man nicht bewegen konnte, schon bewegt hat.
Achso, ja klar. Kameras waren ja auch noch so riesige Teile, die große Stativ brauchten.
Zusammenschneiden, der ganze Produktionsablauf dazu. Das muss ja Horror gewesen sein. Cutting, dann hast du Filmmaterial, was beim kurzen Kontakt mit einer Lampe gleich in Flammen aufgeht. Wir haben dann auch schon damit rumgespielt, Überlagerungen gemacht und mehrfach belichtet. Ganz weit. Da sind auch alle Remakes heutzutage, mögen schöne Bilder haben oder sonst irgendwas. Aber nichts ist so weit draußen, wie es damals war. Sowohl von der Idee her als auch von der Umsetzung her.
Heute müsste man schon alles in 3D machen.
Holografisch oder so. Keine Ahnung. Die Nanopartikel einzeln in der Luft.
Okay, also Ruttmann, wen hast du noch genannt? Richter, Hans Richter. Und dann hast du noch einen Herrn Fischinger erwähnt, der auch so ähnliche Videos gemacht hat.
Eigentlich der Coolste. Ruttmann ja, der ist halt mit Hype hier, gerade auch in Berlin, und sehr gerne gesehen, wegen der Symphonie in der Ruhrstadt und so. Aber ich stehe eigentlich noch viel mehr auf den Herrn Fischinger. Auch wieder so ein kanales Mensch, der sein ganzes Leben lang nicht mit Geld umgehen konnte. Der ist dann auch ganz arm mit sieben Kindern irgendwo im Burkling, glaube ich, in so einem Hinterhof gestorben, ohne dass ihn irgendjemand beachtet hat. Jetzt fangen an, Leute wieder sein Werk herauszugraben. Das Verdienen war es auch ein Lebenswerk, wirklich die perfekte Symbiose zwischen Musik und Bild zu machen. Und der hat auch bei Herrn Rothmann mit gearbeitet. Er hat ihm vor allen Dingen vorgeschlagen, für seine Filme seine Wachsmaschinen-Erfindung, das sind halt auch alles Geeks. Die haben auch immer alle gebastelt, immer mit irgendwelchen Schrägen, was auch immer so gefunden.
Klar, die Technik gab es nicht, die sie brauchten, da mussten sie sich ihre Maschinen selber bauen. Was hat er denn gebaut? Eine Wachsmaschine?
Eine Wachsmaschine, ja. Und zwar hat er verschiedene Farben Wachs zusammen gegossen. Und die Wachsmaschine hat immer ein Stückchen von der Wachsmaschine abgeschnitten und ein Foto gemacht. Damit hast du halt einen unheimlich psychedelischen Tunneleffekt. Weil dieser Wachs, musst du dir vorstellen, Wachs fließt so einander. Wenn du jetzt immer eine Scheibe davon abschneidest, hast du halt immer, du zooms da so rein in den Wachs. Das ist wie ein 3D-Objekt. Wir hatten das mit dem 3D-Objekt für Blinken. Wenn du ein 3D-Objekt so aufschneidest, so nach hinten, so langsam irgendwas durchschiebst, hast du genau die gleichen Effekte.
Wie so ein Marmorkuchen.
Genau, genau. Und das hat er damals halt erfunden. Und der Herr Rothmann fand das auch ganz toll. Und da hat er so ein bisschen Geld für gekriegt. Aber viel interessanter ist halt, dass Herr Fischinger dann, hat dann auch noch bei ihm Frau Mond von, wie heißt er, der Metropolis, Fritz Lang. Frau Mond hat dann auch ein paar Visual Effects gemacht. Da ist es auch interessant, das verbindet mich so ein bisschen mit ihm, weil viele Visual Effects-Leute halt auch diese Verbindung immer gesucht haben. Diese Verbindung zu den Visual Effects ist auch immer da.
Und Potsdam, deine Region.
Und Potsdam, ja, genau. Komposition im Blau hat er dann gemacht. Aber sein bedeutendstes Werk ist eigentlich Walt Disney's Phantasialand. Da wird er nicht im Abstamm genannt. Das ist eine ganz traurige Geschichte eigentlich. Der hat diese Idee gehabt, Comic und Story mit Musik zu verbinden. Er hat diese Idee erfolgreich an Walt Disney verkauft. Er hat dann auch mitgearbeitet an Phantasialand. Dann haben sie ihn rausgekickt, weil er etwas viel Abstrakteres und Krasseres vorhatte, als Mickey Mouse da tanzen zu lassen. Er wollte auch Mickey Mouse tanzen lassen, aber nicht in den Vordergrund gestellt. Da haben sie ihn rausgekickt aus dem Team.
Phantasialand ist einer der ersten Filme von Disney.
Ja, einer der ersten Abendfilme.
Aber auch die ganze Zeit mit Musik.
Ja, es ist Musikvisualisation. Eine Stunde lang.
Keine gesprochene Geschichte.
Und zwar geht es um den Rück, den Goethe, das Faust. Da geht es darum, dass da... Wo die Geister, die ich rief, werde ich nicht mehr los, ist Faust. Darum geht es in der Geschichte. Gütet ja auch wieder Farbmusik, also das ist... Zauberlehrling, Entschuldigung.
Ich lese hier gerade nochmal kurz parallel, das ist ja immer nicht so hilfreich, wenn man das macht, aber ich sehe gerade hier, Fantasia ist wirklich voll mit Musik. Von vorne bis hinten. So, also Herr Fischinger, der irgendwie Abstrakt-Art-Artist, geht in die USA und er sozusagen...... Ich bin daran schuld, dass Disney dieses Projekt aufgenommen hat. Aber am Ende kriegt er die Credits nicht dafür.
Man sieht auch, die Stellen, die von ihm sind, sind nur deutlich viel stärker und viel besser als der Rest. Man sieht das, wenn man auch seine anderen Werke, die kurz davor entstanden sind, so sieht. Da sieht man schon, das ist halt sein Stil, mit vielen kleinen Figuren, die tanzen und Formen machen, in der Masse Formen machen. Da gibt es auch noch eine Zigarettenwerbung von ihm, die kurz vorher Phantasia hergestellt hat für irgendeine italienische Zigarettenmarke. Mir fällt das nicht ein. Diese Elemente kommen dann auch um Phantasia mal wieder. Vor allen Dingen gibt es Charaktere, dann gibt es eine Story, dann gibt es natürlich die Verbindung zu Musik und Formen. Ganz viele Formen, wo eigentlich ein normales Bild, was du in einem Bild siehst, und da mit den Formen gespielt hat in dem Bild. Das ist natürlich auf Cartoon-Ebene, aber da hast du halt eine Treppe oder so, und die Treppe wird dann halt zum Beat, sag ich mal. Die Kamera geht dann so über die Treppe hinweg, der Charakter geht so hoch die Treppe, und jede Treppenstufe macht halt so zu einem Beat. Das ist unheimlich revolutionär. Das hat man auch danach nie wieder so gesehen. Das ist auch vollkommen gestorben. Und dann halt auch Cartoons zu benutzen, und nicht gleich Realbilder. Comics haben auch einen ganz interessanten Aspekt, nämlich dass bei Comics du im Kopf die Verbindung zwischen zwei Frames herstellt, also bei gedruckten Comics. Und er hat das auf dieses Musikvideo-Konzept übertragen, dass du halt eine Szene siehst und die nächste Szene siehst, die jetzt erst mal irgendwie so nicht so richtig was zu tun haben miteinander, aber im Kopf, und sowieso schon die Handlung sehr konfus ist, weil keine Sprache ist und so, aber du dir die Handlung im Kopf zusammenbauen kannst, weil es ist schon so abstrakt genug, dass vielleicht jeder eine andere kleine Nebenhandlung noch sieht oder so. Das ist so, wo ich auch hin will. Das ist total genial, da bin ich...
Ganz heiß drauf. Also, dieser Herr Fischinger scheint ja irgendwie dann auch der totale Freak zu sein. Hatte neben dieser Wachsmaschine noch andere Sachen gebaut? Oder fallen sonst noch solche speziellen Technik-Konstruktionen ein, die jetzt so für psychedelische Optik hergestellt wurden, um eben so eine visuelle Gestaltung zu machen?
Ja, dann nicht vom Fischinger selber. Ich glaub, der hat auch noch mal ein paar andere Sachen gebaut. Aber was genau, das ist jetzt nicht so aus dem Kopf. Also der war auch immer kreativ. Aber eigentlich, so hätte es auch schon ein bisschen so in der Zeit, wo dann schon so Elektrozität anfängt und so. Und wo dann auch die Produktionsmöglichkeiten, was den Film betrifft, auch ein bisschen besser werden. Wollen wir denn schon jetzt einen kleinen Sprung machen, meinst du da, oder?
Einen kleinen Sprung? Dann machen wir die ganze Zeit kleine Sprünge. Die Frage ist, ja, ich meine, was wir versuchen, ein bisschen zu ergründen, ist so, wie hat sich das jetzt eigentlich entwickelt? Wir haben jetzt irgendwie das Audiovisuelle, wir sind jetzt irgendwie beim Film.
Genau, was ja auch immer nicht live sind, muss ich noch dazu sagen, natürlich sind die toll, diese ganzen Filme, diese abstrakten Filme, aber das ist halt alles reproduziert.
Während wir jetzt bei der Höhlenmalerei noch so voll in der Live-Performance waren.
Genau, und auch versucht haben, den Farborgeln, das ist halt auch noch live, sind wir jetzt aber schon wieder ein bisschen mehr zurück in die aufgenommene und abgespulte und immer wieder abzuspielende Variante gegangen, was natürlich dem Ganzen ein bisschen Spontanität nimmt und auch so ein bisschen Feedback.
Gut, aber dafür hat man auch Zeit, sozusagen für eine spezielle Performance auch das so vorzubereiten, damit es auch wirklich impressive ist.
Genau und perfektionieren. Wie gesagt, der Fischinger glaubt, sein letztes Werk hat da glaube ich 25 Jahre dran gemalt. Ölmalen, das ist nicht fertig geworden. Ist dann irgendwann gestorben, wie gesagt. Irgendwo, also das ist total krass. Ich hab da zu Hause einen ganz kurzen Videoschnitt, den findet man garantiert nicht auf YouTube. Das ist ganz rare. Epochal, also was er da mit Öl gemalt hat, das ist, also Öl, jedes Bild mit Ölmalen und richtig detailliert und Formen, die miteinander morfen. Das funktioniert alles zur Musik. Das ist alles super, echt krass. Aber für das sind wir auch nicht fertig geworden. Das möchte ich dann nie kennen.
Du hast ja auch ganz andere Produktionsmittel. Was auch so im Vorgespräch kurz anklang, ich schneide durch Wachs, und diese ganzen psychedelischen Eindrücke kommt natürlich sofort der Gedanke an 2001. Stanley Kubrick. Da gibt es diese großartige Sequenz gegen Ende des Films. Stargate heißt es, glaube ich. Wenn man den Film das erste Mal sieht, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir ging, spätestens an der Stelle, wenn man schon mal so zwei Stunden durch den Film ist, da ist man sowieso schon jenseits von Gut und Böse. Und dann irgendwie diese absurde Sequenz, wo der Protagonist, kommen wir jetzt nicht drauf, wie im Delir durch diese Farbwellen fliegt.
Dieser Effekt? Der Effekt hat auch was damit zu tun. Der sogenannte Slitscan-Effekt wurde von John Whitney erfunden. Und der John Whitney hat seinen Ursprung auch in der Formmusik, sage ich jetzt mal. Sein allererstes Werk hat er ein M5 Anti-Flugzeug-Kanonenradar, das muss irgendwie aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg irgendein Radar, einer der ersten Radars gewesen sein, der irgendwo abgestaubt und hat damit Formen gemacht, also Musikformen, so ein bisschen aus Soloskop-mäßig.
Mit einem Radar-Gerät?
Ja, man kennt das ja, da geht immer so ein, ich weiß nicht, wie es aussah, ich habe kein Bild, nie gefunden, aber es ist wahrscheinlich so ein rundes Ding, wo dann halt so ein Strahl, so ein Kartonstrahl draufgebeamt wurde und dann hast du dann mal Piep, Piep, Piep gemacht. Das hat er halt gehackt, also hat er halt dran rumgelötet und rumgeschraubt und hat damit Bilder, Effekte erzeugt zu Musik.
Mit einem Radargerät, das war sozusagen sein Monitor.
Das war sein Monitor, genau, es hat auch abgefilmt und hat dann daraus so...
Das heißt, er muss im Prinzip so diese Radar-Echos erzeugen, nur in einem bestimmten Muster, um dann eben diese Muster auf den Bildschirm zu haben. Und was hat er gemacht? Hat er da irgendwie dann mit einer Radar-Pistole auf Schildkröten gehalten oder was?
Das ist sketchy, ich weiß nur, dass er damit angefangen hat. Und es muss der totale Hit der psychedelischen Szene in den 60ern gewesen sein, was er damit erklärt hat.
Das war schon wieder bei den Drogen.
Ja, also was er damit so erzeugt hat mit diesem Gerät, das war... Aber vor ihm, kurzer Sprung, deswegen hab ich ihn gefragt, deswegen hab ich den Cue nicht mehr aufgenommen. Vor ihm gab es halt noch eine Frau, die dort zuerst so mit Oscilloskop Musik visualisiert hat und damit auch das allererste Mal Musik live input und Bild entsteht. Man kennt alle Oscilloskope, kann man halt Strom reinlegen und dann kriegt man eine Sinuswelle oder irgendwas. Jeder kennt den Ausschlag, iTunes Visualizer sag ich jetzt nur, wie das aussieht, wenn man Musik in einen Oscilloskop rein tut. Mit dem Oscilloskop gibt es 1000 Ablenkungseinstellungen. Gerade bei den alten gab es noch mehr Regler. Man hat damit rumgespielt und dadurch Formen, die immer zu Musik reagiert haben, weil die Musik das Eingangssignal war, immer Formen erzeugt. Mary Ellen Bute.
Auch eine Britin?
Ich glaube, das war sogar eine Amerikanerin.
Und wie war die so drauf? War das jetzt auch so eine Künstlerin, die nichts anderes gemacht hat?
Die kommt irgendwo ganz woanders her.
Das klingt so ein bisschen mehr, als wenn sie immer im Labor gearbeitet hat, bis sie immer auf die Idee gekommen ist, ihren Labor zu machen.
Die hat irgendwo mal eine Theorie von irgendjemanden gelesen, also nicht jetzt irgendeine von denen, sondern eine physikalische Theorie, wie Musikwellen mit visuellen Wellen so verbunden werden können. Und daraufhin ist sie in diesen abstrakten Film-Dings reingekommen. Sie hat sich mit Wunderkerzen experimentiert, die ersten Filme, die sie so gemacht hat, und ist dann irgendwann zu diesem Osteoloskop gekommen. Das muss irgendwas mit ihrem Beruf zu tun haben. Tamaric kann mich nicht mehr erinnern.
Das erste Visualisierungsgerät für solche Echtzeitvisualisierungen.
Auch die erste Frau, die da auftaucht. Das stimmt. Plato und Goethe. Gibt es denn mehr? Im Laufe der letzten Jahrhunderts kommen wir dann noch zu Wegweisenden. Die Wegweisendste überhaupt, dass auch eine Frau schräg ist. Die key Stellen ins Elektronenzeitalter haben immer Frauen besetzt.
Wie hieß er noch gleich?
Herr Whitney? Der hat auch rum experimentiert, hat viele von diesen psychedelischen Filmen gemacht und wurde dann angestellt für Space Odyssey, der dieses LitScan-Technologie, die er entwickelt hat, einzusetzen. Man merkt auch irgendwann wieder, diese Filmmusik oder diese audiovisuelle Kunst hat auch immer wieder einen Impact in wirklich bedeutenden Werken. Phantasial war damals auch schon ein extrem bedeutendes Werk. Und Symphonie einer Großstadt und auch The Man of the Moving Camera. Das waren alles so Werke, die wirklich bahnbrechend waren für ihre Zeit. Und immer wieder ist da diese Verbindung da. Das ist für mich natürlich spannend.
Jaja, die Technik. Gerade jetzt im Filmbereich ist es logisch, dass Technik dann auch immer wieder mal so eine Zeitwende eingeleitet hat. So die Special Effects bei Star Wars oder so. Oder hier irgendwie der Matrix-3D-Trick. Ist ja ganz klar. Aber wir sind ja jetzt beim Schwerpunkt audiovisuelle Kunst. Und dieser Effekt hat dann 2001, also Slitscan, das ist halt, ich hab schon mal darüber gesprochen, wir wissen nicht genau, wie es funktioniert, aber im Wesentlichen halt ein Schlitz in einer Maske, durch die hindurch der Film belichtet wird und dadurch entstehen halt diese Effekte.
Dahinter ist eine Rolle mit irgendwas Gemalten drauf oder so und das wird durchgerollt und durchgezogen und mit Langzeitbelichtung und nicht Brechung.
Und schon wird es total trippig.
Mega trippig.
Ich kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass irgendjemand 2001 noch nicht gesehen hat hier von den Leuten, die hier zuhören, aber wenn ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt, dann ist das irgendwie euer erster Download, nachdem dieser Podcast durchgehört ist.
Definitiv.
Die Szene gibt es natürlich jetzt konkret auch online. Schnell mal bei YouTube zum Klicken.
Ja, aber jetzt wird es halt auch richtig spannend. Wir sind jetzt so im Oscillatoren, Elektrizität. Die Frau Büt hat wie gesagt das erste Mal dann auch Audio direkt visualisiert durch die Oscillatoren. Und dann kommt aber auch schon der Fernseher relativ schnell. Wann ist eigentlich der Fernseher? Das muss doch auch Ende der 50er gewesen sein. Kannst du mal die Müllhalde befragen?
Du meinst, weil der Fernseher seinen Durchbruch gehabt hat?
Nein, nicht der Durchbruch, sein Debüt.
Sein Debüt? Na ja, die ersten Bildschirme gab's natürlich auch schon so 20er-, 30er-Jahren, wo das irgendwie dran rumgefummelt. Also sein Durchbruch hat das dann erst, zumindest bei uns erst, nach dem Krieg gehabt.
Ganz klar. Auf jeden Fall Fernseher, das war total spannend für die Leute, die sich halt nach wie vor in Massen und auch immer mehr eigentlich für dieses Film, dieses audiovisuelle Ding so interessiert haben, weil nämlich da ist eine wildgebende Röhre drin und alle, die schon mal eine Röhrenfernseher so benutzt haben, wissen, dass man eine Box zum Beispiel, eine Audiobox daneben stellt, kriegt ja schräge Farben.
Man mit Magneteneinfluss nimmt und dann eben diesen durch einen Magneten geleiteten Strahl abfängt.
Richtig, und man kann halt auch an Sachen hinten rumdrehen und den Strahl ablenken, indem man da irgendwo hinten an den Steckern. Das ist natürlich alles gewährlich, weil da ist viel Strom drauf, aber da kann man super geile Sachen mitmachen.
Kann man zum Oszilloskop umbauen.
Kann man zum Oszilloskop umbauen, kann man aber auch zum Video-Synthesizer umbauen.
Wer jetzt schon ein Magnet in die Hand genommen hat, vorsichtig, das kriegt man dann irgendwann nicht mehr raus.
Na gut, aber wir hatten noch einen Röhrenfernseher.
Ich hab noch einen.
Ja, ich auch.
Soll aber die Tage vorbei gehen.
Meine Notizen sind weg, oder?
Man muss auch nicht immer alles ablesen.
Nö, ich lösche mir die Augen. Man muss mich schon dran denken, hey, ist das so viel? Ich hab ja bloß immer ein Wort stehen.
Ich will ja keine Kritik äußern.
Ich verlier mich dann aber auch ganz schnell.
Der Fernseher nimmt natürlich einen extremen Raum ein. Gerade was so das Audiovisuelle betrifft, irgendwann ging es ja halt los mit Fernsehen und irgendwann ging es vor allem auch los mit diesen Musikvideos ohne Ende.
So weit sind wir noch gar nicht.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt?
Wir sind jetzt in Anfang der 70er. Also Ende 60er, Mitte 60er, Anfang der 70er. Die Video-Synthesizer, die man nämlich aus diesen Fernseheröhren gebaut hat.
Video-Synthesizer.
Also Geräte, die Bilder synthetisch erzeugen. Synthetisch erzeugen, genau.
So wie auch die Audio-Synthesizer zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Genau, da gab es den MOOC, der Audio-Synthesizer MOOC. Aber es gab halt zum gleichen Zeitpunkt...
Hier winken Leute rein.
Es gab halt zum gleichen Zeitpunkt Video-Synthesizer. Und natürlich, wir wissen, als LSD und so, das kam halt alles so gerecht in Zeit, nämlich trippige, schräge Formen zu erzeugen.
LSD kam rechtzeitig zum Synthesizer.
Oder andersrum. Also das passte gerade zusammen zu der ganzen Zeit. Da kann ich jetzt auch wieder nebendropping machen, weil jetzt kommen mir jetzt auch die Leute, die man mit audiovisuellem Kram zusammenbringt, wie Namjong Paik, Woody und Steiner Basulka.
Den Namen hab ich schon mal gehört, aber ich krieg's jetzt nicht zugeordnet.
Namjong Paik, ein ganz bekannter Videokünstler. Mainstream ist er als Videokünstler bekannt, aber er ist schon so Audio-Video zusammen. Das ist so sein Ding. Hat auch politische Kommentare gegeben, hat Fernseher übereinander gestapelt. Da gibt's diese Fernsehpyramide von ihm, die ist ganz bekannt, die hat man schon mal gesehen.
Okay, ist klar, da kenne ich das auch her.
Die trafen sich alle im sogenannten Kittchen, das war eine alte Küche von einem Hotel am Broadway in New York. Da haben sich diese ganzen, die sie mit Video-Synthesizers experimentiert haben, so zusammengefunden. Bekannt sind halt Woody und Sterner, weil die haben das so dokumentiert. Die haben auch heute noch eine Webseite, die müssen wir auf jeden Fall verlinken, ganz interessant. Auch mit Videos und Bildern aus dieser Zeit ganz viel. Und Video-Synthesizer gab es en mass. Also wirklich, da hat halt jeder irgendwann mal irgendwo noch einen Konsensator mehr an diesem Fernseher angeschlossen und andere Formen damit erzeugt. Irgendwisches Patchwork, irgendwelche, schon Pixel-Grafiken damit schon gemacht, so teilweise, also ohne Computer, sondern halt wirklich so Patch. Video Viva hieß der, der sieht aus wie Pixel-8-Bits-Grafiken, die der gemacht hat. Aber so der am schönsten, also von mir jetzt, von Bill Hirn, wird er wahrscheinlich ausgesprochen, H-E-A-R-N, wunderschön, farbliche Kreise, die miteinander morphen und du kannst halt wirklich stundenlang zugucken. Das ist einfach nur schön. Auch teilweise in Musik gesteuert, teilweise nicht. Manche Videos haben auch nur Video-Effekte gemacht, also sehr harre Video-Inputs und dann halt das koloriert, zum Beispiel der Pike A, A-B, wahrscheinlich. Der nam jungen Pike hat zusammen mit einem Herrn Ape A-B-E ein Video, das heißt, er entwickelt nur Farben, Solarisierungseffekte, wenn ich das jetzt mal wieder so Graustufen rausnehme und dafür Farben ersetze, und das sah dann alles so bunt und eckig aus. Das war so von dem jungen Pike so das Merkmal. Das kam halt alles aus dieser Richtung Audiovisuell-Kunst. Da müssen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen, wir haben ja schon ein bisschen Zeitprobleme langsam, oder?
Ich hab kein Zeitproblem. Man, das ist, ich würd jetzt auch gerne, wir müssen ja jetzt nicht jedes Detail der Geschichte beleuchten. Was halt jetzt wirklich interessant ist, ist einerseits, wie lange das sich schon die Hand reicht, wie große Auswirkungen es jetzt auch hat auf Film, Kunst, auf, ja, auch gesellschaftliche Zeit, wie es sozusagen so eine Beimengung ist. Ich spring jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen vor, so auch in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren aktiv erlebte Zeit, gerade so diese Techno-Generation. Da kann ich mich noch sehr gut erinnern, da fing das dann auch bald an, nachdem also Anfang der 90er Jahre sich so elektronische Musik in zunehmendem Maße, in den Mainstream vorgearbeitet hat, noch nicht da war, aber sich ganz klar angemeldet hat, gesagt hat, okay, wir übernehmen jetzt mal hier das mit Trockenrohr, ist jetzt vorbei, jetzt kommt Techno und viele Künstler haben sich daran dann angehängt. Und dann ist mir dann irgendwann mal so dieses Video in die Hand gefallen. Ich glaube, das waren auch so die ersten Dreilux hier auch aus Berlin. Kennst du sicherlich, die halt auch angefangen haben, okay, wir nehmen jetzt mal die Musik und komponieren Bilder dazu. Das war dann so, wenn man sich das heute anschaut, diese Bilder, wirkt das wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr simpel und einfach war. Aber damals natürlich auch schon ja so totale Augenöffner. Krass, was ist das denn? Und dann haben sich halt diese Kassetten gekuft und auf der Party einen Fernseher geschmissen, also einen Videorecorder geschmissen und abgespielt auf dem Fernseher. Das war ja auch sehr stark dann. Und dann hat man halt einfach gesehen, wie diese visuelle Kunst dann auch wirklich ein festes Standbein wurde dieser gesamten kulturellen Bewegungstechnik. Ich sag jetzt mal bewusst nicht Musikbewegung, weil es war für mich, sicherlich nicht nur für mich, eben eine sehr breite kulturelle Bewegung, die eben die Musik im Vordergrund hatte, aber dann eben gleich in der zweiten Reihe auch schon mit einer ganzen Reihe von anderen Sachen kam. Auch so hier im Print hat sich das verändert, hier so solche Sachen wie Frontpage. Also auf allen Fronten wurde mit anderen gestalterischen Ausdrücken gearbeitet. Und das Video war dann ein Teil davon. Und dann kamen sie dann halt, die VJs.
Kann ich die Geschichte kurz abschließen?
Ja, genau, darauf würde ich jetzt auch ganz gerne irgendwie kommen. Und ich frage mich halt jetzt, was diese Brücke dieser letzten 10, 20 Jahre war, was sich da jetzt sozusagen entwickelt hat, dass es so weit überhaupt kommen konnte.
Okay, also es gab diese Video-Synthesizer, die konnten halt Bilder generieren. Das war schon super. Da ist wieder live. Da sind wir wieder beim Aspect Live. Und dann kommen halt die ersten Computer. Super, super geil. Muss ich ganz kurz erwähnen. Groove Vampire, das war eigentlich der erste Computer, wo man mit Audio live generieren konnte. Der Groove, der hieß Groove. Generating real-time operations on voltage controlled equipment. Das ist ein 24-bit DDP224 analog digital music performance Gerät. Und diese, wie nennt man sie, eine Frau, Lauri Spiegel, hat diesen Groove Vampire umprogrammiert und hat damit das allererste Mal ein Programm geschrieben, womit man real-time Video machen konnte. Und sie hat auch den Griff real-time Video dort das allererste Mal eingesetzt. Dieses Gerät sollte zuerst Groove RTV heißen, das heißt Groove Real-Time Video, hatte dann umbenannt in Groove Vampire, nämlich Groove Vampire als Video- und Music-Playing Interactive Real-Time Experiment. Also, der war schon möglich, da live Video zu performen drauf, oder live Bilder komplett digital zu generieren. Also der Input war noch analog, also da gab es halt einen Logopotentiometer, an dem man so dreht hat, aber das Generieren an sich war digital. Und dann kommt natürlich auch die Videorevolution, wo jeder Keks sich halt ein Video-VHS-Dings kaufen konnte und damit halt auch der, ich renne jetzt hier mal durch.
Ich bin ja gerade am Gucken hier zu diesem Groove Vampire, das war ein riesen Gerät. Das ist ja hier wie so ein alter Computer, ich füll ja komplette Racks.
75 oder so, ne?
70 sogar. Aber wer hat denn den? Also ich meine, wie viel gab's denn davon?
Einen.
Es gab da genau einen von. Okay, alles klar, das ist so wie mit alten Computern, da gab's dann auch mal genau einen von.
Ja, die hat uns erst Programm geschrieben, wie gesagt, das zu machen, war sehr interessant.
Wie hieß die junge Dame?
Die junge Dame hieß, hab ich gerade gesagt, Laurie Spiegel.
Laurie Spiegel. Und die hat dann irgendwie...
Ja, real-time gemacht, da gibt's auch keine Überlieferung, weil es nur live war und das hat auch keiner aufgenommen. Das war auch nur in diesem Labor. Das kam dann nie raus.
Und jemand weiß, welche Musik?
Die Musik wurde auf der Groove-Seite auch erzeugt. Aber das 70. Also das ist so als Meilenstein, das erste Computer mal im Hinterkopf. Und dann kommen wir so Ende der 70er, da gehen die Videos und das heißt ein bisschen in den Hintergrund. Dann kommen auch Computer ein bisschen mehr in den Vordergrund. Dann gab es dann schon die ersten Macintosh. Da gab es auch ein Programm. Da habe ich jetzt aber keinen Namen und so. Das Programm habe ich, aber da hat der erste auf so einem nicht Macintosh, da waren die noch nicht Apple. So ein Apple II, nämlich der erste Videogenerationsprogramm geschrieben, so 78, 79. Da war doch auch der Amiga später sehr stark. Video kommt noch zu der Zeit, also richtig...
Aber Video live mit dem Apple II?
Nein, das war noch nicht Video mit dem Apple II. Das war noch simple Grafiken. Also irgendwie generative Grafiken.
Ja, aber das ist ja noch nicht gerade die Computer-Generation, wo man jetzt schon wirklich so viel Power zur Verfügung hatte.
Das ist wieder interessant. Sobald ein technisches Gerät da war, wurde damit versucht, audiovisuelle Kunst zu machen. Egal, in der gesamten Menschheitsgeschichte. Da haben wir wirklich ein bisschen hinaus. Eigentlich haben wir alle nur gewartet darauf, dass wir ein performancestarkes Gerät hatten. Da krieg ich gleich den Bogen ganz zum Ende.
Kann man ja auch zu Hause machen. Jedes Gerät taugt. Dann könnte man ja auch irgendwie so eine batteriebetriebene Lampe nehmen und so ein bisschen Farbe. Und dann wirft man das einfach in seine Waschmaschine rein und schaut zu. Schon mal gemacht?
Naja, ich hab auch schon viele Experimente gemacht.
Aber das noch nicht?
Nee, Strom in der Waschmaschine? LED-Lampe habe ich schon rum experimentiert.
Strom in der Waschmaschine, ja. Die Waschmaschine ist ja eh Strom, aber du machst halt einfach was, was ist. So eine Lampe, die irgendwie so in so einem kompletten Lichtball enthalten ist. Mein Einstieg in die Videokunst, aber ich glaube, das hat keine wirkliche nennenswerte Zukunft.
Ja, wir sind jetzt noch dran stehengeblieben. Videorevolution, wie gesagt, es gibt dann die ersten VJs, große Heim, aber das ist schon das erste Mal so Heimkameras. Also ich meine, muss man sich vorstellen, wie Filmproduktion für einen Menschen zu Hause eigentlich nicht machbar. Du hast einen ganzen chemischen Prozess daran. Du kannst nicht einfach jetzt einen Film produzieren auf Film. Du brauchst dann teuer wie Sau, super anstrengend, super kompliziert, musst den Film bestimmt handeln. Dann kamen auf einmal Video-Bänder, magnetische Bänder, wo man einfach simpel auf Rekord drücken konnte und aufnehmen konnte. Das hat natürlich einen unheimlichen Boom gebracht. So auch Ende der 70er so rum. Da gibt es den ersten Videomischer. Der erste Videomischer, also ein Videomischer ist ein Gerät, um zwei Video-Quellen zusammenzumachen. Weil nämlich sich einer gedacht hat, nämlich der Herr Peter Dohnbauer und Richard Monkhaus, die beiden haben sich gedacht, wäre ganz cool, wenn man jetzt hier so Videotapes abspielt und die irgendwie live zum Musikmischen kann. Und haben damit einen Videomischer gefunden.
Das war sozusagen der Sinn. Warum ein Videomischer gebaut wurde.
Genau, der Videokalos.
Das ist auch ein Videomischer schon im Fernsehen.
Nein, das kam danach. Und die wurden alle auf Grundlage dieses Gerätes gebaut. Nein.
Echt?
Ja, das war auch für mich damals ziemlich sure ausgezogen.
Das heißt, obwohl jetzt, ja gut, ich meine, magnetische Aufzeichnung hat wahrscheinlich auch eine Weile gebraucht, bis das im Fernsehen also gehalten war. Das war ja am Anfang auch alles im Prinzip live. Und noch bevor sozusagen der Bedarf dort entstanden ist, oder sie überhaupt auf die Idee gekommen sind, gab es schon diese künstlerische Initiative.
Video Carlos Image Processor.
Und damit konnte man dann von Tapes vorbereitetes Zeug acht Quellen zusammenmischen.
Mischen, also Fading, und bestimmt verschiedene Vibe-Effekte, was man heute immer noch in den Videomischern hat. Also diese Cheesy Vibe rechts, Vibe links, Zoom-out Vibe, keine Ahnung, diese Sachen waren da schon im allerersten Gerät drin.
Wie haben die das zum Einsatz gebracht, das Teil?
Ist nicht klar. Ist halt nicht gefunden. Ich würde gerne immer noch mehr Details zu diesen Angaben gehabt. Ist halt sketchy, ist halt nie richtig alles dokumentiert.
Die Jungs können ja fast noch leben, oder?
Ja, habe ich nicht. Wo sind die denn her? Wo haben die denn das erfunden? Monkhaus? Richard Monkhaus und Peter Donabauer.
Haus mit wie Haus oder wie Haus?
Ja, und das war so um die 70, 80 rum. Also wir kommen jetzt in die 80er Jahre. Und da wird es nämlich crazy. Weil in den 80er Jahren, ich glaube 1982 oder 1983, kam ein Fernsehsender ins Fernsehen, der sich MTV nannte. Und mit diesem Zeitpunkt starb diese komplette Szene, die da in den 70ern riesengroß war, viele, viele Künstler, eigentlich komplett aus. Es gab noch so zwei, drei. Peter Rubin, muss ich ihn mal nennen. Auch den hab ich noch kennengelernt. Als ich ihn kennengelernt hab, noch den selbste VJ, sag ich mal, der auch mit Video und auch mit diesem Videomischer damals schon umexperimentiert. Der hatte in den 80ern auch noch ein bisschen weiter gemacht. Aber so richtig so gekickt, so wie in den Jahren davor, wo halt hunderte irgendwelche Video-Synthesizer gebaut haben und experimentiert haben, in den gesamten 80er-Jahren eigentlich gar nichts. Also nichts gefunden. Also ich bin auch immer offen, wenn da noch irgendjemand sagt, ja, da gab's dann noch das und das, kleine Projekte hier und da, aber es war nichts von diesem Impact, der da in den Jahren davor irgendwie da war, zu sehen. Obwohl jetzt dann natürlich diese Video auf einmal da war, zu benutzen. VJs, billig, günstig, könnte sich jeder hinstellen, miteinander mischen, aber so richtig bahnbrechendes Kram nicht. Und dann kommen wir schon in die 90er und in den 90ern fängst du dann halt wieder an, spannend zu werden, weil dann kommt nämlich die Computer.
Ja, bei den 80er Jahren, ich meine, das war ja im Prinzip, das hast du ja anfangs schon gesagt, es gab immer dieses Bedürfnis, Musik und Bild zusammenzubringen und vor allem ein Bild zu erzeugen zur Musik und jetzt nicht nur Musik zum Bild. Das ist doch eigentlich das, was in den 80er Jahren dann auch stattgefunden hat. Also es war dann vielleicht nicht live, aber die ganze Musikvideokultur, ich mir vorstelle, Anfang der 80er Jahre, wie da noch ein Musikvideo aussah und dann zehn Jahre später, was sich da getan hat, das war doch schon wirklich ein wichtiger Entwicklung in dem Zusammenhang auch. Sie sind nicht verschwunden, sondern sie sind, sie haben sich einfach auf einem Medium, einem anderen Medium konzentriert. Genau, und es nicht mehr live gemacht, sondern viel Zeit darauf verwendet, irgendwie auch eine Sprache zu finden.
Ist auch okay. Also ich möchte das jetzt auch gar nicht sagen, das ist böse, böse oder sonst was.
Nee, du hast das nicht verstanden. Es hat nur so den Eindruck, die sind dann alle zehn Jahre in Urlaub gegangen und sind dann später erst wieder gekommen. Aber was hat man denn da rausgezogen? Also ich meine jetzt, was war denn sozusagen die visuelle Essenz aus dieser Zeit?
Kurz, ja, da kommen wir wieder, jetzt sind nämlich wieder Geschichten, hat funktioniert, auf einmal kurze Geschichten ohne Sprache mit Musik zu verbinden. Das ist, was der Musikvideo ist. Eine schnelle Bildsprache, also auch Schnitz um Musik zu finden. Also zu sagen, wie kann ich jetzt schneiden, dass das passt so in einer Szene. Also eine langsame Szene eigentlich, so zu schneiden, dass es schnell wirkt oder passend zu Musik, rhythmisch wirkt. Und die haben natürlich auch, wenn man auf vielen Musikvideos sieht, Elemente aus diesen ganzen Jahren davor mit benutzt. Also es sind halt auch trippige Elemente mit drin. Also das auch zu verbinden mit Masken und mit, also wirklich auch eine Produktionstechnik aufzubauen, die mit Layers arbeitet und sowohl spazial als auch zeitachsen. Aber als auch in der Zeit rum experimentiert, also wie das am besten alles zusammenpasst. Da gibt es schon noch viele super Erkenntnisse daraus. Wie viele Leer kannst du übereinander legen, bevor du nicht mehr siehst zum Beispiel. Da gibt es auch ganz flimme Musikvideos, die dann sagen, wir können jetzt die 20 Leer übereinander legen, aber siehst du nicht mehr. Das sind nur noch drei.
Habt ihr denn auch wirklich bahnbrechende Musikvideos, die dir da jetzt auch so ein Stil vorgegeben haben?
Das ist nicht so mein Gebiet. Ich wäre nie so richtig mit beschäftigt, weil es auch so riesengroß ist. Das wäre normal so ein ganzes Ding. Da müsste man bestimmt, gibt es bestimmt viele.
Jaja, gibt es bestimmt eine ganze Menge. Ich grübel jetzt selber gerade, ob es irgendwas gab. Ich meine, was waren denn so beeindruckende Sachen? Ich meine, da gab es zum Beispiel ein Thriller von Michael Jackson, was eigentlich so erst mal schon dadurch durch den Produktionsaufwand total herausstach. Das Ding war ja irgendwie zehn Minuten lang. Aber vor allem auch schon wie so ein kleiner Film, wirklich so eine komplette Geschichte erzählte.
Das war auch so mit ganz vielen Leuten, oder?
Ja, mit Zombies und Tralala und die Flüchtlinge.
Diese ganz vielen Leute ist nämlich eigentlich eine Rückbesendung auf Fischinger, der ja auch diese Gruppe von Leuten in Phantasial hat, permanent, die auch bestimmt in sich eine Form geben. Also die haben da auch schon Sachen eingebaut, die da vorher schon entstanden sind. Also nicht eins zu eins kopiert, sondern gesagt, okay, das war cool, das können wir jetzt auch im Musikvideo benutzen. Es gibt nichts Neues, das hat sich gegenseitig befruchtet. Ja, und dann Anfang der 90er, kam dann die Computer, die haben so das erste Mal über Quicktime und so schon sich die Videos abspielen können. Und natürlich auch so mächtig werden es ja auch schon simple 3D-Animationen, also Drehwürfel. Das sah halt alles noch semi aus, aber ging alles schon auch teilweise live.
Seit wann gibt es denn so VJs, wie man sich das so vorstellt, die in Clubs stehen und dann wirklich Live-Bilder werfen?
Na ja, also der Peter Rubin, sei ich mal, der erste Wicket zurückgehend, der aufgrund einer Technoparty Video miteinander gemischt hat. Also der hat wirklich auch im Osten, der war hier sogar in Berlin im Osten, hat hier so eine Party gemacht, wusste ich nicht, der hat mir Bilder gezeigt. Hier im Palästerepublik haben die eine Technoparty gemacht im Osten, noch zu Ostseiten. Und der hat da gespielt. Echt? Wann? 1987 oder so, keine Ahnung, kurz vor vor. Der hat in der 70er angefangen mit VHS-Videorekordern und diesem Videomischpult, was da entwickelt wurde. Der hatte auch eine der ersten Geräte, hat die miteinander gemischt und hat auch ein bisschen politisch aktiv. Und hat dann auch bei anderen auch ein bisschen links gerichtet, wie Künstler halt so sind. In Russland hat er auch irgendwie gespielt, in Moskau haben sie ihn auch eingeladen.
Aber jetzt sind wir im Prinzip das, was ich vorhin schon so ein bisschen vorweg gegriffen habe, so das Techno-Zeitalter. Was ja mehr ist als nur die Musik, was ja auch so dieses, die Computer sind da, wir benutzen das jetzt, elektronische Werkzeuge, Speicherung, die gesamte Bearbeitung von Audio hat sich ja auch innerhalb sehr kurzer Zeit total revolutioniert. Und das Video war ja dann technisch immer nur ein, zwei Jahre dann hinterher gewesen, war so mein Eindruck. Also wenn auch immer irgendwas mit Audio gemacht werden konnte, konnte man dann ein, zwei Jahre später dasselbe dann auch mit Video machen. Und ja, wann bist du da dann auch konkret eingestiegen?
Also so richtig, so meine erste Sache war so 1999. Also die erste Public-Sache. Also eingestiegen zu Hause und verfreundet. Und so war das schon 1995, 96. Aber so wie ich jetzt gedacht habe, ich bin jetzt irgendwo in front of a crowd und mach da VJs, war so 1999.
Und was war dann dein Material da? Also was, hast du dann auch VHS-Tapes mitgebracht?
Nee, nee, also ich hab schon rechnerbasiert. Einmal allererster Gig war mit sieben DV-Kameras, die da gerade neu auf den Markt kamen, irgendwie. Muss H8 gewesen sein. Sieben. Und zurückgespult und Tapes eingelegt. Und dann haben mir meine Eltern von der Firma so ein Videoeffektgerät ausgebaut, so 19 Zoll Rack. Super schwer und war auch das erste und einzige Mal, dass ich so was gemacht habe. Und Tvek gesagt hat, sie ist ein Aufwand hier. Und es war super, es war live und es war wirklich on the beat. Konnte ich echt Sachen mixen. Noch gar nicht drüber nach, das war Tic-Tac-Mix, aber da war es mal on the beat und irgendwie schick und konnte Effekte und hat irgendwie gepasst. Aber der Aufwand, dass sie dieses riesen Effektgerät damit zu schleppen und diese Kameras da zu synchronisieren und versuchen an Laufen zu halten. Dann hast du Dropouts und Bandsalat gehabt und so weiter. Da hab ich mir schworen, dann nie wiederzumachen. Dann hatte ich schon immer ein Powerbook, ein rumtrage Computer, das ich toll fand. Da gab es dann dieses G3 Powerbook, irgendwie diese schwarze mit dem umhydrierten Apfel. Können Sie das erinnern?
Ich kann mich daran erinnern, ja.
Auch so das Allererste davon, schwache Ufterbooster. Da hab ich dann ein Programm gefunden, das nannte sich Videodelic. Das gibt es auch immer, glaube ich. Mit Videodelic kannst du Effekte machen auf Videobilder. Total rudimentär. Vor allem brauchst du unbedingt einen MIDI-Controller, um das Programm zu benutzen. Das kannst du gar nicht über Tastatur oder so benutzen. Also nur ganz rudimentär, aber ein bisschen mehr zu machen. Aber du konntest auch von den Videosachen nicht mehr so viel erkennen danach. Weil das waren so Graustufen, 128, 128 Pixel Auflösung. Und dann konntest du da farbige Effekte drauflegen. Und das hat schon immer geruckelt und nicht wirklich super. War okay, also für die Maschine damals war es flüssig. Muss ich mich sagen. Aber war jetzt nicht High Quality, High Definition Videogramm. Und auch keine High Quality Grafik.
Ich wollte jetzt mal so ein bisschen, weil wir uns jetzt auch so langsam dem Ende der Sendung nähern, vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen weg von der Geschichte. Ich denke wir sind jetzt auch an dem interessanten Punkt angekommen, wo sich einfach diese VJ-Kultur entwickelt hat. Was so ein Phänomen für sich ist. Und was ja so ein bisschen unverstanden ist. Weil es dann, wie ich es schon angedeutet habe, natürlich lange Zeit auch erstmal im Schatten da sein fristete. Der DJ war ja dann immer so der Star auf der Party. Und VJs standen vielleicht auch noch mal irgendwo auf dem Flyer. Aber so recht hat das immer so keiner mitgenommen. Ich selber habe immer so das Problem gehabt, nicht nur bei Partys, generell bei Veranstaltungen, fand ich eigentlich Video immer dann auch extrem distrusting. Also wo auch immer. Es gab ja dann auch so diese Unkultur, generell an so Tanzlokalen dann immer irgendwelche blöden Filme zu zeigen. Und was mich daran sehr gestört hat, war, dass sehr häufig, fast immer, das Zeigen von Filmen, die Kommunikationsstruktur auf der Veranstaltung komplett auseinander gerissen hat. Leute standen dann von diesen Bildschirmen, starten dann irgendwie die ganze Zeit auf die Wand, weil sie wie eben auch dieser Effekt beim Fernseher, man sich einfach nicht vom Bild lösen kann, und einfach so das Miteinander, weswegen man ja eigentlich auf so eine Veranstaltung geht, zerrissen war. Das ist schon auch ein grundlegendes Problem bei VJs, oder? Also nicht beim VJs, beim Präsentieren von so visuellen Sachen auf solchen Veranstaltungen. Wie begegnet man dem? Was treibt den VJ? Das würde mich wirklich interessieren.
Das ist natürlich ganz, ganz schwierig zu beantworten. Aber bei mir kam das so in Stufen. Ich hab halt angefangen, mich komischen Sachen zu machen. Die waren halt so beatgenau, und das war schon irgendwie spannend. Aber wie du halt auch so sagtest, das nervte auch teilweise, es flickerte nur. Du hast da nichts rausgezogen, aus dem Bild, was du da gesehen hast. Ich war nie ein Fan gewesen von irgendwelchen Videos, von irgendwelchen Filmen zeigen und so. Da bin ich ja auch total strikt dagegen. Ich bin auch eigentlich strikt dagegen, nur zu samplen, weil zuerst da ist die, der in der Speech ist, wirklich da rauskommt. Na ja, so aus Filmen. Irgendwelche aus Hollywood-Filmen machen ganz viele.
Irgendwelche Clips rausnehmen und die zeigen.
Die halt neu zusammenmischen und dann zeigen. Die erste Erfahrung war eine ganz schlimme Veranstaltung, die ich eigentlich nur gemacht habe, weil man muss ja auch irgendwie sein Equipment finanzieren. Laufstern Galaktika, ich kann es ja mal so sagen. Es waren 25.000 Leute. Ich stand auf der Bühne. Laufstein? Laufstern Galaktika zur Love Parade, irgendwas in der Messehalle. 20.000 Leute. Die standen alle vor mir. Audio, Video, ganz klar. Riesengroß, leimant, richtig geile Technik. Bei so einem Veranstalt ist es natürlich schick, weil du musst dir irgendwas kümmern, dann kannst du dahin, klappst deinen Lapper auf, ob alles gut ist. Die Musik fiel aus, aber der Video nicht. Es war irgendwie Strom weg, keine Ahnung. Ich stand auf der Bühne und habe die Crowd gehabt. 20.000 Leute schauen dich an. Und schauen mich an. Und ich habe dann damit gespielt. Ich habe sofort gesagt, das ist jetzt hier eine Chance, alles auszuprobieren, was du dir in deinem Leben jemals vorgestellt hast. Und ich habe die Leute, bis die Musik wieder angeht, mehrfach zum Schreien gekriegt. Zum Testen, Bilder zeigen, Rhythmus, ein anderes Bild zeigen. Es gab keine Musik, den Rhythmus auch mit der Musik erzeugen. Mit dem Bildern erzeugen, mit dem Schnitt. Und dann kann man ein Stroboskop ein bisschen anmachen. Und dann im Dunkel-Hell arbeiten oder so. Also wirklich ohne Beat-Reaktion versucht die Leute zu animieren. Und die haben wirklich mehrfach Schreien.
Was hast du denn für ein Material hinzugefügt?
Na, das war so meine, die ich auch jahrelang aufgebaut habe, so meine Standard-Bibliothek, die ich bis vor drei, vier Jahren eigentlich immer benutzt habe. Also was ich so gesehen habe, vier Blinkenlites, aber halt auch, bin halt viel durch die Welt gereist, so Sachen aufgenommen, Menschen, Großgesicht, Emotionen, aber auch Wasserfälle. Also was ein klassisches VJ-Bandtapetenmaterial sei. Jetzt mal tanzen, Menschen passen auch immer gut. Bin auch einmal mit ein paar Kumpels hier durch Berlin gefahren und wir sind halt irgendwie krass auf der Straße, hab ich die einfach tanzen lassen.
Das heißt, du hast auch deine eigene Footage erzeugt?
Ist mein eigenes Footage, komplett. Also alles, was ich spiele, immer schon gewesen ist. 100% mein eigenes Footage. Und danach, nach dieser Geschichte, also nach diesen fünf Minuten, haben wir in die Musik wieder gekommen und so weiter und hast auf einmal gemerkt, dass ein ganz anderes Feedback auf einmal zu dem Video auch weiterhin da ist. Also da war die Musik zwar schon wieder da und die Musik hat halt auch Höhepunkte gehabt, aber ich konnte auf einmal mit der Musik und die Leute steuern. Das war für mich... Und die hatten weiterhin ihre Party, wie sie normalerweise ihre Party da hatten. Die haben auf einmal darauf reagiert, was ich gespielt habe. Das war für mich unheimlich crazy. Da hat es mir so gezeigt, Leute darauf, ja, also wenn Leute da mehr drin sehen als in Wandpapete und auch gemerkt haben, dass es sie beeinflusst. Das beeinflusst dich. Wenn du im Bild im Club läufst, beeinflusst das deine Stimmung. Genauso wie die Musik unter dem Hollywood-Film die Stimmung des Films beeinflusst. Das ist andersrum genauso, dass die Bilder genauso stark sind wie die Musik. Sie sind immer so stark. Das ist natürlich auch eine Aufgabe für so einen VJ, den meines Erachtens nicht viele so sehen. Viele VJ-Sachen, die ich sehe, die machen halt Bilder, die meistens rhythmisch auch super perfekt auf den Beat mittlerweile passen. Die Software ist auch easy. Die Bilder wirklich zappeln zu lassen zur Musik, das gehört nicht mehr viel zu. Aber du beeinflusst die Stimmung der Leute. Ich hab auch mehrfach schon Partys beendet, weil ich keinen Bock mehr hatte, die Party-Scheiße war. Und ich dann halt wirklich nur noch Clips gespielt, wo ich gesagt hab, Leute sind in 10-20 Minuten von der Tanzfläche.
Was zeigt man denn dann?
Friedhöfe oder was? Also unterschwellig irgendwelche, die so polarisieren, schlechte laute Menschen irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Regen, Bilder, irgendwie so Kram halt. Und keiner weiß warum auf einmal die Stimmung im Saal runtergeht. Du kannst es steuern, du kannst es definitiv. Ich will mir eine Handfeuerung nehmen, dass ich das noch mal schaffe. Leute aus dem Club, woraus ich ekel kann mit Bildern. Ohne jetzt wirklich ekelige Bilder zu zeigen. Also wirklich nur Stimmungsbilder, die halt eine Verbindung bringen.
Und die Leute wissen es gar nicht?
Die wissen es nicht, was da passiert ist, warum es jetzt so ist. Du merkst halt, die fangen weniger an zu tanzen und haben jetzt nicht mehr so die überschwenkende Stimmung. Gerade wenn das Drogen sind, ist das noch viel einfacher. Weil sie natürlich da viel mehr drauf reagieren. Und dann tropfen wir Wasser an, bis am Zug oder so. Also wirklich so am Fenster von einem Zug oder so. Da hab ich so einen Clip, der halt so richtig so reisen.
Okay, das könnte man ja im Umkehrschluss sagen. Das wäre ja dann auch der Beweis dafür, dass man sie auch positiv erhellen kann.
Ja klar. Und das ist halt auch die eigentliche Aufgabe für eine normale Clubabend, sag ich mal. Das ist auch die unterste Level, wo ich sage, wenn ich einen VJ sehe, auch von mir aus, dass ich in den Club gehe, ja, das Beat, dass das auf den Beat irgendwie passt. Also auch wenn es nicht immer auf den Beat sein muss, aber dass es irgendwie zum Beat der Musik passt, das ist das unterste Level. Und das zweite Level ist, wenn der VJ es schafft, ja, die Musik, das Gefühl der Musik auch zu nehmen und das zu verstärken oder zu umzuwandeln in seiner Interpretation davon. Und damit halt auch dieses Feedback Leute, DJ, VJ aufbaut. Also nicht nur Leute, DJ hin und her, sondern halt, dass da ein Dreierfluss entsteht.
Sprichst du dich mit den DJs eigentlich irgendwie ab? Also ich meine...
Ich würde super gerne, aber...
Wie informierst du dich? Das geht gar nicht mit denen.
Nee, für die interessiert das überhaupt nicht. Also 90, 95 Prozent der DJs, mit denen ich zusammengespielt habe...
Aber bist du also der Bildhampel irgendwie?
Ich hab... also klar, ich kann natürlich mit Freunden, DJs, die mittlerweile natürlich auch sensibilisiert wohnen, dafür ist das natürlich eine andere Sache. Aber du kommst dahin und bist meistens nicht mehr gegrüßt. Du bist halt ein Techniker, der da irgendwie knapp verdrückt. Ah, ich hab Macht. Das verstehen sie meistens nicht. Und wenn sie dann wirklich richtig arrogant sind, funktioniert ihre Party irgendwie nicht und sie wissen nicht warum.
Die Rache des VJs.
Naja, es ist auch teilweise wirklich arrogant. Du kriegst ein Zehntel des Preises, was dann ein DJ kriegt, und stehst meistens über sechs DJ-Sets da, anstatt nur ein DJ-Set wie der DJ.
Gut, aber die Leute kommen natürlich auch primär wegen der DJs, die spielen, und nicht so sehr wegen der VJs.
Möcht ich mich nicht beschweren.
Aber so ist es.
So ist es halt. Aber ich möchte ein bisschen Respekt für mich zum nächsten haben. Das ist ein scheiß Job. Das ist 11, 12 Stunden im Club und denen fliegen die Ohren weg danach. Und du kriegst kein Feedback. Also manchmal kommt halt der Crowd. Wenn du wirklich gut warst, merkst du es schon, dann kommt halt. Ich hab heute nur wieder mal Leute, hab die hochgekommen, nach Tamei. Es war toll. Das hat mir einen Abend echt versüßt, weil du da gespielt hast. Freut man sich natürlich auch. Aber vom DJ kommt sowas nie.
Also du musst einfach nehmen, was kommt und interpretierst einfach die Musik in Echtzeit. Weil du nicht weißt, was vorher kommt. Das heißt, man muss auch wirklich seine Bibliothek gut kennen. Ich meine, gut, das geht auch für einen DJ. Der muss auch seinen Platten gut kennen, damit er sich wiederum auf die Leute einstellen kann. Riechst du dich mehr nach der Musik oder nach den Leuten?
Das ist ein Feedback. Beides ist gleich wichtig. Aber ich bin ein bisschen weiter mittlerweile. Das war mein VJ. Das ist das VJ, was man so sieht, so im Groben und Ganzen. Wir haben jetzt noch 12 Minuten. Ich versuch's noch kurz einzubringen.
12 Minuten kann man noch mehr erzählen.
Wie gesagt, durch mein Diplom. Eigentlich die Idee dazu hatte ich, es geht halt um Live-Cinema, es ist Geschichten erzählen in der ganzen Geschichte, in dem Kontext VJ, wirklich eine Story zu erzählen, wirklich mehr zu machen als Gefühl und Beat, sondern auch den Leuten mehr Wert zu geben, wenn sie hingucken. Also nicht, dass sie hinstarren, darum geht's mir nicht, dass sie jetzt da hinsitzen und die ganze Zeit hingucken und sagen, okay, es ist jetzt Fernsehen, sondern sie gucken da mal hin und wieder hin und nehmen aber was mit von. Das ist für mich als, ich hab eine kurze Aufmerksamkeit, ich kann teilweise nicht mehr Filme gucken im Kino, langweilig mich total, so ein Zwischenmedium. Man geht an den Club und kriegt halt noch einen Film nebenbei mit. Man kann sich trotzdem weiter unterhalten und Freunde treffen und so weiter. Und diese Attention Disorder Generationen anzusprechen mit der Geschichte.
Ist das dann wirklich so eine linear erzählte Geschichte oder arbeitet das dann auch so mit einer Repetition, wie man das auch in der Musik hat? Hast du da sozusagen auch deine Loops, dass bestimmte Geschichtsteile auch immer wieder erzählt werden?
Also darauf gekommen bin ich, dass ich in diesem ursprünglichen VJ Set mal einen Typen hatte, der mit dem gelben Koffer eine Treppe hochgelaufen ist. Dann hatte ich noch einen, der irgendwo meine Straße langgelaufen ist. Dann hatte ich noch einen, der wieder die Treppe runtergelaufen ist. Da habe ich irgendwann mal irgendwo gefragt, ob man in einer Party mal hintereinander spielt. Dann dachte ich, irgendwie möchte man jetzt aber eigentlich wissen, was der mit dem gelben Koffer macht. Da kam dann noch einer hoch und meinte, was passiert denn jetzt mit dem? Da hatte ich gesehen, da kam wirklich jemand, den ich nicht kannte, hoch zu mir und dachte, was ist denn jetzt los?
Jetzt hast du angefangen, jetzt musst du es auch zu Ende bringen.
Da kam mir so, das ist natürlich eine tolle Sache. Wenn da Leute, so unterbewusst, wie sie dann hingucken, trotzdem eine Story drinnen erkennen können, die eigentlich gar nicht da war, die eigentlich wirklich rudimentär war, da war eigentlich nur dieser gelbe Koffer und der gleiche Typ, zwischendrin auch noch mal einen Rhythmusloop gebracht. Und da hab ich dann angefangen zu forschen, was kann man machen und wie kann man eine Story darunter bringen und bin ganz weit gekommen. Game Design ist ein ganz großes Thema, also alles, was so ein nicht lineares Erzählen ist. Du hast ja gesagt, es ist eine lineare Story. Ja, es ist im Groben und Ganzen eine lineare Story mit ganz vielen nicht linearen Komponenten drin. Ich möchte halt weder verlieren, dass ich zur Musik reagieren kann, noch möchte ich verlieren, noch möchte ich, dass die Leute die ganze Zeit hingucken müssen. Das soll immer an dieser Club-Atmosphäre dienen, auch ohne jetzt Kino zu sein. Und das soll trotzdem mal diese Story weiterbringen. Es müssen Schauspieler sein, die dürfen nicht reden, weil ich natürlich den Audi-Channel nicht kontrollieren kann. Also ist es eher wieder auch Stummfilme, wo wir ganz zum Anfang wieder zurückkommen. Und eigentlich ist alles zusammengebracht. Alles, was wir hier die letzten zwei Stunden nur erzählt haben, auf den Punkt gebracht.
Interaktiver Stummfilm. Mit dem modernen Oszilloskop, dem Computer. Das heißt, du planst richtig so eine Geschichte, wie man einen normalen Film machen würde. Aber er ist eigentlich mehr aufgebrochen in einzelne Clips. Aber du musst ja dann auch immer noch die Musik interpretieren. Du musst ja dann immer noch zu dem Verlauf der Veranstalter, wenn das nicht im Mittelpunkt steht. Nee, ich möchte das nicht im Mittelpunkt.
Gleichwertig würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Also gleichwertig zur Musik schon. Ich möchte das schon auch mal rausheben aus dem, wir sind jetzt der Drittklassiker, sondern das ist nicht der Fall. Das ist schon wirklich dann auch ein anderes Event, obwohl es schon eine Party ist oder so. Es ist schon nochmal ein bisschen anderes Event, als das, was da rund rum gestrickt wird. Ja, und geplant, das ist wesentlich komplexer als ein normaler Film, weil du brauchst halt Möglichkeiten, auf einen Musikwechsel zu reagieren. Das heißt, eigentlich brauchst du Parallel-Stories. So ein bisschen Quentin Tarantino hier in der Pipe-Fiction hat das so ein bisschen vorgemacht, wie man so Parallel-Stories untereinander mixen kann und trotzdem kommt da am Ende die gleiche Story heraus.
Und vor allem auch nicht in einem direkten zeitlichen Ablauf. Richtig, genau. Wo auch Dinge gezeigt werden, die später stattfinden. Und dann kommt noch mal was anderes davor.
Genau, andere Charaktere haben andere Sichtweisen oder die haben auch ein anderes Gefühl. Das ist jetzt mein anderes Moment, dass ich verschiedene Charaktere verfolge, die dann natürlich sich untereinander treffen. Aber jeder der Charakters hat halt irgendwie ein anderes Rhythmus und ein anderes Bildgefühl dabei. Und wenn jetzt der Musik krass wechselt, wechsle ich halt auf den anderen Charakter. Und da macht dann die Musik auch Spaß. Also da funktioniert das dann auch super. Wenn die Musik wirklich wechselt, kann ich dann auch ganz katt auf meinen Charakter gehen. Das funktioniert alles, ohne dass man das hinterfragt. Und man folgt trotzdem noch der Story und fügt die so zusammen. Da hab ich auch Tests gemacht mit dem Teil der Story, die ich dann irgendwann mal ganz gerne hätte, wenn ich mal irgendwann Zeit hätte, die fertig zu produzieren. Kalkinen Revelation, das war auch mein Diplom-Film-Thema. Kalkinen Revelation, da gibt es keine Website, keine Garnik, so dass man live sieht und nichts findet. Auf dem Westen, bei meinem Blog, könntest du erst viel reinpacken. Da frag ich manchmal, wenn ich das performe. Ich hab wirklich Freunde genommen, die nicht die Story kannten. Die hab ich da reingesetzt und gesagt, passt auf ein bisschen, man braucht aber nicht jetzt die ganze Zeit hingucken, aber erklärt mir danach die Story, ich erkläre sie euch nicht. Und sie haben alle bis ins kleinste Detail. Und ich hab auch zugeguckt, die haben auch Tanz nebenbei und alles, ob ich ins kleinste Detail mir erklären könnte, was da passiert. Und ich war total enttäuscht, dass sie mittendrin abbricht, weil ich halt noch nicht fertig bin. Das ist natürlich schwierig. Das sehe ich so ein bisschen als eine Zukunft vom VJen. Natürlich die ganzen Leute, die halt sehr abstrakt arbeiten und so, möchte ich jetzt nicht runtermachen. Sie haben auch ihre Berechtigung. Und wie wir ja vorhin gesehen haben, ist da auch viel möglich. Und die werden auch immer weiter irgendwas machen können. Aber ich möchte das fusionieren. Das ist mein Ansatz. Das ist mit Kino zusammen.
Siehst du dich da jetzt als Einzelkämpfer oder kennst du auch andere, die eigentlich schon ähnlich narrativ arbeiten?
Es gibt ein paar, die narrativ arbeiten. Hier in Berlin auch Fredan Flux. In England auch noch zwei Leute. Es ist aber sehr... Die wirklich narrative Stories dort reinbringen, das ist ein sehr geringer Anteil. Die meisten machen abstrakte Videokunst. Das Live-Cinema wird auch noch viel im Zusammenhang gebracht mit VJ Solu, die aus, kann ich wohl die ursprüngliche Komplimente sein, in Barcelona, die aber noch ein bisschen noch mehr einen abstrakteren Ansatz daran hat als ich. Also ich mach da schon mehr Film. Also schon mehr richtig Story-Film. Und sie macht das so auf, Gedichte irgendwie abstrakt nachzuerzählen.
Vielleicht noch ein paar Worte zur Vernetzung. Es gibt ja, ihr seid ja viele, und es gibt da auch eine, wie soll ich sagen, so eine Bewegung, so eine Vereinigung.
Hier in Berlin.
Unter dem verwirrenden, also einerseits in Berlin, das ist dann Visual Berlin, richtig?
Visual Berlin, genau.
Aber es gibt ja auch diese europäische Projektierung, gibt es hier noch, das Avid-Projekt?
Pst, wir dürfen den Namen nicht verwenden. Oh, ich hab's nicht gesagt.
Aber unter dem Namen ist es jetzt über Jahre ja auch immer wieder präsent gewesen, AVIT, muss ich gleich klarzumachen. Das mit dem Namen ist jetzt problematisch?
Ja, Patentkram, klassische Scheiß, den keiner Bock hat, sich drum...
Gibst du einen neuen Namen?
Nö, wir versuchen den noch zu kriegen. Wir haben richtig das angefochten. Ich darf da gar nicht drüber zu erinnern.
Okay, aber sag doch mal, was die Bewegung war.
Es gab halt eine VJ-Konferenz. Wir hatten vorhin diesen Farbmusik-Kongress und darauf aufbauend 100 Jahre später gab es dann 2001, 2002? Wann haben wir Blinkenlights gemacht? Blinkenlights war 2002? 2002 gab es einen Lied. Da bin ich direkt von Blinkenlights dahingegangen. Kannst du dich erinnern?
Daran kann ich mich noch erinnern, dass du das erwähnt hast. Du hast in Paris, als wir Blinkenlights auf der Bibliothek nationale France gemacht haben, auch live auf dem Haus gemixt. Tolle Sache. Danach bist du dann gleich zu dieser Konferenz gefahren.
Ein paar VJs haben versucht, eine Konferenz aufzubauen. Du kennst das ja von ganz Null. Am Abend haben wir einen Shoppingcenter bekommen. Im Tage schon, als das Shoppingcenter offen war, haben wir Workshops gemacht und einen langen Tisch. Das war ganz lustig. Am Abend eine riesengroße Party mit 40 VJs. Das war bombastisch. Das war total geil, weil wirklich ein Snapshot an diesem Zeitpunkt, wo es gerade auch anfangen, dieser Laptop-Generation, ein Snapshot von allen VJs zu sehen, da bin ich auch der glücklichste Mensch der Welt, als ich das gesehen hab damals. Das war wirklich von der ganzen Welt kamen, die haben alles selbst finanziert, hat keiner Geld gekriegt, keiner Geld verdient. Das war wirklich einfach gemacht.
Totales Projekturenfestival.
Gleichzeitig 40 VJs, also nicht hintereinander, sondern gleichzeitig projiziert in diesem Leads Einkaufszentrum, was auch relativ geil ist. So ein halbrundes Ding. Und es fand dann noch ein paar Mal statt. Also dann England vor allen Dingen noch 2-3 Mal, dann hab ich es ja nach Berlin.
Dann warst du zu Gast beim Kongress?
Genau.
Zwei Mal?
Genau. Auch im Camp erst mal, ganz, ganz klein.
Genau, auch beim Camp, genau.
Und nächstes Jahr wollen wir eigentlich ein größeres machen. Ob das jetzt so stattfindet oder nicht, das ist noch nicht ganz so nahe prozentig raus, aber wir wollen jetzt hier in Berlin wieder eins machen. Also das größte eigentlich war in Brighton vor zwei Jahren.
Gibt es da eine Webseite zu?
www.evit.info glaube ich sogar.
Noch heißt sie so. Irgendwann aber nicht mehr so.
Genau.
Na gut Falk, das war unsere Tour de force.
Ich muss mal ganz kurz noch, wenn Leute in Berlin VJs sind und wollen sich connecten, visualberlin.org, die treffen sich hier in Donnerstag irgendwie in so einer kleinen Bar und machen da ein tolles Treffen. Das ist wirklich ein sehr entspanntes Miteinander und beisammen sein. Connecte euch mit den Jungs, die sind alle total offen und wollen auch mal.
Kann ich bestätigen, dass es eine sehr offene Szene ist, soweit ich sie kennengelernt habe. War ich sehr beeindruckt, auch so von dem hohen politischen Anteil. Aber wir verlagern alles weitere in die Zukunft und beenden jetzt hier die Sendung, weil wir müssen natürlich hier pünktlich übergeben. Das war Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 96. Und ich sage danke Falk für die Ausführung, für den Blick in die Zeit und vor allem auch hier in die Realität. Mal gucken, vielleicht greifen wir das irgendwann nochmal passend wieder auf. Ich bedanke mich auch fürs Zuhören. Das war's, bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.